Tim Ferriss: KevKev, nice to see you.
Kevin Rose: TimTim, pleasure.
Tim Ferriss: Ladies and gentlemen, as you
may have surmised, every opportunity to use
surmise I will take.
This is another episode of The Tim Ferriss
Show, and it is also another episode of The
Random Show with my first-ever podcast guest
and my perpetual friend —
Kevin Rose: Number one.
Tim Ferriss: Bestie numero uno, Kevin Rose.
Kevin Rose: Worst show ever.
But we did it.
Tim Ferriss: You've got to start with a rough
draft.
You've got to start with a rough draft.
Kevin Rose: You had this list of questions.
You asked me what my favorite cereal was or
some shit like that.
I was like, "Tim, you should not ask your
guests that."
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, you were like, "Oh, it's
one of those shows."
And then I was like, "Oh, my God.
I thought this was going to be a layup with
kid gloves, but Kevin's busting my balls in
episode one."
But it was good.
Kevin Rose: It was fun.
Tim Ferriss: It worked out.
Kevin Rose: We got a little hammed in that
one, but it was fun.
Tim Ferriss: We got a little hammed.
Speaking of ham, what do you have over there?
We're having a drink, sharing a virtual cheers.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, we're having a drink.
Yeah, cheers to you.
Let this be known to the audience and to the
world that this was the first time I didn't
want to drink and Tim pressured me into drinking.
Normally, it's the other way around.
Tim Ferriss: I pressure you.
All right, just to replay the tape here.
I said, "Do you have a drink?"
And you're like, "No."
And I was like, "But I have a drink."
You're the one who's always busting my balls
about having a drink.
Kevin Rose: Right.
It's okay.
It's Friday.
Tim Ferriss: Right.
Well, you said, "It's 3:00 p.m."
And I said, "But it's a Friday."
And you're like, "You don't really need to
say Friday.
You can just say drinks."
And then you walked off and got a drink.
I wouldn't say, I'm not sure if pressure,
I mean, unless you've got —
Kevin Rose: It wasn't really twisting an arm,
was it?
It was more just like a slight change of wind
direction.
I was on my way to —
Tim Ferriss: It was like a fingertip-to-the-lips
kind of pressure.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, exactly.
Shh.
Say no more.
Tim Ferriss: Say no more.
Sleep.
Go get a beverage.
So we have a lot to talk about.
It seems like you've got a big list.
I have a big list.
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
What are you drinking, by the way?
Tim Ferriss: It's always the case.
Kevin Rose: We didn't talk about that one
yet.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, yeah, we didn't even talk
about it.
Well, what do you have?
You go first.
Kevin Rose: I have some shitty champagne.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, okay.
Yeah.
Kevin Rose: Nothing worth mentioning.
Tim Ferriss: This is, I'm going to have to
pronounce this because I don't speak French,
much like you might say, Versailles, Kentucky.
There is a Versailles, Kentucky.
This is French.
I don't speak French, but you've got this.
It's a Bandol, B-A-N-D-O-L, appellation Bandol
Controleé 2021.
Then there's Domaine Tempier at the top, and
this —
Kevin Rose: Love that Domaine Tempier.
Tim Ferriss: — Domaine Tempier.
It was recommended to me, actually bought
for me by a friend.
I'll call him Jay, not to dox him, he's not
Jay-Z, but a good friend of mine and it's
fantastic.
It's really nice.
I put some ice in it just to be a heathen
and to harken back to the days of old when
I was in Argentina where they drank a lot
of wine with ice and I got into it.
And cheers, Kevin.
Nice to see you.
Kevin Rose: Cheers.
Actually, I've been doing ice in my wine as
well.
Darya's been giving me shit about it, my wife,
and I said, "You know what?
It's hydrating at the same time, getting a
little extra water in there."
That was my rationale.
That said, I don't know if you looked up the
price of that bottle, but you might be doing
it a severe disservice by adding cubes to
it.
I don't know if it's an inexpensive bottle
because sometimes that can be a big faux pas.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I'm okay with it.
Kevin Rose: It's like a $400 bottle.
Cubes of ice.
Tim Ferriss: My whole life is just a series
of faux pas.
What would that be?
Faux pas.
Well, okay, this is very unclear.
It says price, $25.47 to $672.
So, it's somewhere in that range.
I don't know, it looks like $55.
But I do think it may be somewhat challenging
to get, but it's not an over-the-top —
Kevin Rose: At the end of the day, if you're
enjoying it with some ice.
Godspeed, right?
Tim Ferriss: We could go on a whole line tangent.
Kevin Rose: Speaking of Godspeed.
Tim Ferriss: Let's speak of Godspeed.
Kevin Rose: Can I start with my first thing
to talk about?
Tim Ferriss: Oh, I can't wait to see this
segue.
Yes, please.
Kevin Rose: Okay, so we've got a lot to talk
about.
One of the things that I would say we are
known for at The Random Show is just random
shit, and it's just like, okay, we don't see
each other for three, four months.
What have we stumbled into that's stupid,
that's fun, that's creative, that's whatever?
Fill in the blank.
And it's all kinds of stuff.
One of the things that you're quite good at,
Tim, that I really enjoy as part of The Random
Show that we do is you're always talking about
how can I get the most value and satisfaction
out of something that is low-dollar value?
Meaning, is that how you typically phrase
it or?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, like affordable luxuries.
Kevin Rose: Affordable luxuries.
Tim Ferriss: Something like that, right?
Kevin Rose: Right.
So, that sounds right.
So, there is the most, I would argue, outside
of a standard Rolex Day-Date, the most popular
watch in the world for watch nerds, I'd say
probably recognizable watch, would be the
Speedmaster, which is the watch that was worn
to the Moon.
And it's an Omega Speedmaster, the original
caliber that went to the moon, I think it
was a 321.
It gets really geeky.
The very first Speedmaster that you can buy,
the first very release, is now worth hundreds
of thousands of dollars for a representation
of Speedmaster.
Modern day Speedmasters from Omega, you can
still buy them, they are, I have to check
the price, but let's call it three and a half,
$4,000, somewhere around there.
Maybe a touch more.
I haven't looked in a while.
That said, they did a collaboration, Omega
did with Swatch, and at first glance, you
think like, "Swatch, there's no way.
Why would I want," but the actual collaboration
looks amazing.
It looks just like the Speedmaster.
Tim Ferriss: Wow.
It looks identical minus the band.
Kevin Rose: Identical.
Exactly.
Tim Ferriss: It's super, super similar.
Kevin Rose: It's got the chronograph.
It's made out of the ceramic that is super-durable.
They just crushed it and they made them in
a whole variety of different colors.
They put a different planet at the bottom
of each one.
So this one is Saturn right here, this brown
version.
They're impossible to get and you have to
buy them in the store.
You can get them on eBay, but if you go into
the stores, they actually have a limit to
the supply they kind of dole out each day.
Tim Ferriss: What's the price range or the
cost?
Kevin Rose: $250 or $290, something like that.
Tim Ferriss: Definitely cheaper than $100,000
and cheaper than $5,000.
Kevin Rose: And you get the exact look of
the Speedmaster and it's such a fun watch.
Tim Ferriss: That's cool.
It's really iconic.
It's a super-iconic watch.
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
So, if you're always been Speedmaster-curious
or want to have one of the most iconic looks
in terms of watches, no, I'm serious, but
that's why it went from Godspeed to here.
You can see the jump.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I see it.
Kevin Rose: It's just a cool watch and you
got to see all the different colors, man.
Tim Ferriss: It is a great watch.
Kevin Rose: So, they call it the MoonSwatch
instead of the Moonwatch.
Tim Ferriss: That's clever.
Kevin Rose: So it's the MoonSwatch from Speedmaster
and Swatch collaboration.
Yeah, just always trying to find something
that is — holidays are not that far off.
If you have a watch lover or someone in your
life that you want to do a gift to, great
gifts as well.
So it's kind of fun.
Tim Ferriss: For folks who may not know also,
the Swatch Group is the world's largest watch
company.
Employs about 36,000 people in 50 countries.
They own a whole line —
Kevin Rose: Huge.
Tim Ferriss: — of different brands, including
Omega.
Kevin Rose: Yes.
That's why this happened.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, exactly.
So, there you go.
Kevin Rose: You have to imagine the people
at Omega were pissed.
I just know so much about this industry.
Tim Ferriss: They might have been like, "We
decline your suggestion."
And then the parent company was like, "No,
this isn't a suggestion.
This is what we're doing."
Kevin Rose: Exactly.
"This is actually happening."
Tim Ferriss: And I will say that, and you
know this, I don't generally wear any kind
of jewelry or watches or anything, very, very
little adornment, but I was gifted as a very
beautiful, thoughtful gift, a Speedmaster,
by a friend of mine.
And it feels good to wear this watch.
Kevin Rose: It does.
Tim Ferriss: And also if you want to, it's
kind of like guys who have really good mustache
or beard game, they think the women are going
to be into it, and then they just constantly
get compliments from guys.
That will also happen if you're wearing one
of these things.
Kevin Rose: Oh, 100 percent.
Tim Ferriss: And the fact that you can get
though that Swatch for those people who are
not watching the video, that collaboration,
it looks just like the SpeedyPro.
I mean, it really does.
Kevin Rose: One thing that is worth mentioning
there on this watch, for those that want to
know kind of the two-second geeky backstory
is that Neil Armstrong not only wore this
watch to the moon, but used the chronograph
feature to time the propulsion and jet releases
to land on the moon.
So it's like talk about he had to use a device.
There wasn't computers to do this.
Tim Ferriss: A mechanical device.
Kevin Rose: A mechanical device on his wrist.
And so that's why this watch is like legit.
It's a real true utilitarian awesome tool.
So, it's pretty awesome.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, you can imagine if there
were some wrist-bound computer used for the
first human landing on another planet and
then that was made available in limited supply
for civilians to buy, what that would hold
in terms of meaning.
Kevin Rose: Did you hear about the sealed
first iPhone went for over $100,000 at auction?
Tim Ferriss: No, I did not hear.
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
That was just a few years ago.
Tim Ferriss: That's wild.
That's insane.
Now, you mentioned one thing though.
I'm curious about, you said it's not, you
can't find it on eBay.
How does a company pull that off?
Kevin Rose: No, sorry, you can find it on
eBay.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, you can?
All right.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, that is the place.
You have to either go in-store like to an
actual Swatch store, or on eBay.
There's only two places to find it.
Tim Ferriss: I got it.
You can get it used or if you want it new,
you have to go to the store.
Kevin Rose: Right.
You can't go to swatch.com and buy it directly
from the site.
They won't ship it to you.
Tim Ferriss: What else you got?
Kevin Rose: I've got a lot.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, yeah, bring another one
on and then I'll choose an appropriate transition
from one of them.
Kevin Rose: I'll bring a quickie and then
I've got some really hard-hitters after that.
The quickie is that I'm relaunching my podcast.
Tim Ferriss: Love quickies.
I just want you to keep saying it.
Kevin Rose: You love quickies.
I'm relaunching my podcast.
I'm actually doing it and getting back in
the game.
Tim Ferriss: Which podcast are we talking
about?
Kevin Rose: So I had The Kevin Rose Show from
back in the day.
I shut it down for maybe — it's been about
a year and a half, two years ago, and I've
missed it.
I've missed a lot of what I was doing there,
but also I want to modify it in a few different
ways.
Tim Ferriss: Now this is separate from — unless
I'm already, I've had a third of a glass of
wine, so maybe I'm just hallucinating already.
But Foundation?
Kevin Rose: The Foundation and Kevin Rose
Show kind of merged into one.
So it's still one feed because Foundation
was all about interviewing entrepreneurs,
talking about their entrepreneurial journey,
trials, tribulations, things of that nature.
Tim Ferriss: Speaking about other planets,
you did have Elon on at one point.
This is back in the day.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, so that's actually what
I want to get back to where, when I think
about some of the value that I was able to
add to my listeners, it was around, and something
that I think I've personally been good at
is identifying trends early on and talking
about them before anyone else.
Tim Ferriss: Just to underscore that.
You are undeniably one of the best in the
world I've ever seen at that.
Kevin Rose: I appreciate that, man.
That means a lot coming from you, man.
Tim Ferriss: It's true.
It's true.
I've seen it over and over and over and over
and over again.
Yeah, it's incredible.
Kevin Rose: It's funny.
Someone has a clip of me mentioning Ethereum
for the first time on your show.
Have you seen that?
We did a Random Show.
Tim Ferriss: It was like 1985.
I mean, yeah, it was way back in my apartment
in San Francisco.
Kevin Rose: I'm like, "Let me tell you about
this thing called Ethereum."
Totally.
So, getting back to that, just really wanting
to highlight and expose people to that early
beta — beta, I think of early software.
And so the tentative working title's called
Beta, but it's going to be showing off things
as early as possible that have potentially
a lot of upside for the users.
So, advancements in AI.
When I had Elon on the show back in the day,
Tesla stock was $1.90.
I looked up the price of when he actually
came on the show.
Tim Ferriss: Holy shit.
Kevin Rose: Which is crazy.
So it's going to be a variety show.
It's going to cover tech, investing, health.
And then I think also important to throw in
there is this kind of mental work-life balance
that is so important to me these days where
it's, yes, investing is great, yes, making
money is great, but it's not going to bring
you happiness unless you can figure out the
shit in your head.
So, just making sure that's a component to
it as well.
Anyway, don't have anything to announce, but
I would tell people, by the time this show
comes out, if you just go to kevinrose.com,
you'll see a link to the podcast there.
Tim Ferriss: Have fun.
Kevin Rose: And I'm going to fire it back
up.
Tim Ferriss: Do you have any teasers for likely
or possible guests?
Could be names, could be just profiles.
Kevin Rose: It's a great question.
I had sent Elon an email a while ago and he
said he had a lot of fun on my first show
and was game to do it again.
That was a while ago, but I got to go and
hit him back up.
Would definitely want to have Elon back on.
That's going to be a good one.
But I would say there's three or four, but
nobody is confirmed.
I really want to kick it off with a good banger
to begin.
So, TBD.
Tim Ferriss: TBD.
Well, let me tell you about something exciting
on my side, which is really just a celebration
at this point of enthusiasm for me.
It's not a launch or anything like that at
this point, but you don't know about this.
Nobody knows about this really, which is I
recently, last week, did a, I guess it was
a four-day creative sprint in the middle of
nowhere at this rustic retreat with two writers
and three concept artists who are some of
the best in the world, who have done some
of the best-known work for D&D, for Magic:
The Gathering, and we worked on CØCKPUNCH
stuff, believe it or not.
Kevin Rose: Amazing.
Tim Ferriss: We actually spent that entire
time coming up with scenarios, characters,
adventures, concept sketches, artwork.
I don't want to spoil the surprise.
We made some significant tweaks to the nature
of that realm that I think are very, very,
very compelling and got tons and tons of artwork,
and it's spectacular.
Some of the work is just outrageously, outrageously
good.
What these guys can do in a handful of hours,
it boggles my mind.
It is just beyond my comprehension.
It's really as if, from the writing perspective,
if someone sat down and in three hours, they
just banged out 3,000 perfect words, I'd be
like, "What?
How's that humanly possible?"
I saw that with these artists.
They were so well-oiled, so professional,
and also had very different styles, which
was super-fun.
So, I could watch them also feeding off one
another even though they were working on different
aspects, different greater houses and so on.
For me, part of the celebration is realizing
that even though it was my first go-around,
my first rodeo, and I didn't quite know what
I was doing of course, it was an experiment
in collaboration because I've been such a
solo act.
I've been such a soloist when it comes to
large creative projects.
Having an opportunity to work with, say, not
just one 3D artist, which I did, Walter, for,
say, the initial three-dimensional, 3D Blender
character designs.
But to work with an entire group and to see
if I can actually interact or co-manage that
process in some way was very reassuring.
I think I can do it.
I think that even if I'm not putting pen to
paper or stylus to a tablet in some fashion,
I think the past that I have and the experience
that I have with line art and more recently
with painting and so on, really helps me to
give better feedback to artists and to notice
details.
And I'm very excited about it.
Kevin Rose: I mean, there's a few things I
want to comment on here.
One, it's awesome to see, and it's so apparent
to me now that you launched this as an NFT
project and NFTs are having a bad time right
now.
Tim Ferriss: It's definitely one way to put
it.
Kevin Rose: It's a bloody market out there.
All the proceeds went to a nonprofit.
Royalties are dead.
So the idea that you're making any further
money on this via NFTs is not the case.
Tim Ferriss: Basically zero, yep.
Kevin Rose: And so you're doing this for the
love of the game, which I love to see, which
is awesome.
And the second more important thing, having
known you for a long, long time is I've never
seen you — I've seen you struggle with giving
up a little bit of creative control, like
delegation.
So I'll give you some old Tim Ferriss stories.
Every time Tim would write a new book, I'd
be like, "Dude, Tim, let me get a little early
copy.
Let me get a little chapter.
Let me see what you're working on.
What hacks are you doing?"
Blah, blah, blah.
You wouldn't share that shit with anybody.
You're so secretive.
You'd be like, "How do I encrypt my hard drive?"
You would try and lock down all your shit,
but to see you move into this world of more
of creative director is awesome.
Has that been a challenge for you?
Am I articulating that correctly?
Tim Ferriss: You are.
Yeah, you're definitely articulating correctly.
I mean, I think as we were talking about before
we started recording, we both have some maybe
daddy trust issues or whatever that we've
needed to work through on a lot of fronts
and it's definitely the case that that's true.
I will say that there were a few decisions
that were super-key in facilitating, lubricating,
if you will, the possibility of me acting
in a more creative director role.
So, the first was, and it's easy to miss the
importance of this with the absurdity of the
name of the project.
CØCKPUNCH, The Legend of CØCKPUNCH.
People should check out the trailer at the
very least on the podcast.
Kevin Rose: Oh, my God.
Episode one.
Tim Ferriss: It's so good.
Some amazing voice actors involved and the
key there by using that name.
And this was very deliberate and by pursuing
it the way I pursued it and also giving the
funds to the Saisei Foundation, my foundation,
S-A-I-S-E-I Foundation.org for people who
want to see the projects I'm involved with.
What that did is it basically made fixating
on money kind of silly in the sense that it
doesn't go to my pocket, it's going to the
Foundation, which is important, but it's not
going to directly improve the quality of my
life in any way.
Secondly, the fact that it was given such
an absurd/ hilarious title allowed me not
to take it too seriously or be too precious
or protective of it.
And that is what opened the door to this collaboration.
My hope is that by testing this with something
like CØCKPUNCH, that I will then be able
to translate it to things that I might be
inclined to be more protective with.
There have been so many benefits to this,
and I'll name a few, or I'll at least lead
with one, which is the energy that this has
generated has been unbelievable.
It's been like a power plant for everything
else that I'm doing.
So, it's charging my batteries so effectively
that I've been able to engage much more potently
with everything else.
Kevin Rose: This is creative energy?
This is from the creativity of it all?
Tim Ferriss: Creative energy, creative energy.
For instance, I mean the sort of admin paper-cutty
stuff that is so easy to succumb to, as a
sort of death by a thousand paper cuts.
Look, you need to do your taxes.
There are things you need to do that you don't
really want to do, that deplete, at least
in my case, kind of deplete my batteries.
And if you don't have something on the other
side of the ledger to recharge those batteries,
you can end up being really fatigued.
You just don't have extra calories to allocate
to a lot of things.
This silly project, which has achieved a lot
of serious things, I mean, millions of dollars
have gone to the Foundation, or at least two
million bucks, and there's more that's going
to go because soon I'll be donating all the
secondary royalty revenue also to the Foundation.
I mean, it's done a lot of good in terms of
supporting early-stage science at all sorts
of top universities and journalism fellowships
at UC Berkeley and so on.
But check this out.
This'll be another connection.
And that is I literally, and we'll see if
I can keep this in or not.
I need to talk to the other person.
Kevin Rose: That's how you know it's good.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
I just signed my first-ever writing collaboration
agreement to work on my first book in six
years with another person.
I've never done that before in my life.
And that's my baby, right?
I mean —
Kevin Rose: Is this fiction?
Is this going to be —
Tim Ferriss: This is nonfiction.
Kevin Rose: Nonfiction.
Tim Ferriss: It'll be sort of old-school Tim
Ferriss in a sense, because it'll be what
I'm probably best at and most known for, but
it will be done with someone.
Kevin Rose: Oh.
You adding an hour to the week?
Tim Ferriss: Inflation, baby.
Inflation hits us all.
It's not going to be The 5-Hour Workweek.
Kevin Rose: What's funny is you can release
that and people will be like, "Oh, shit, he
figured out something new," and it'd be like
a bestseller.
Tim Ferriss: The first three or four hours
are all about work, and the fifth hour is
all about pleasure.
Here we go, folks.
Kevin Rose: Exactly.
Tim Ferriss: Epicurean 2.0.
So, I am beyond excited about this because
this is now segueing from cutting my teeth
on some collaboration with this thing called
CØCKPUNCH.
But now I've segued to my actual bailiwick,
right down the middle with hardcore nonfiction,
super-tactical nonfiction, and I'm going to
work with someone else.
And I don't think there's any chance I would
have been able to do that had I not deliberately
created something that I didn't feel too protective
or precious about.
So, I'm fucking stoked, man.
I'm really excited.
Kevin Rose: Let me ask you a question.
How do you decide to, and as a general tip
for the audience out there, how and when do
you decide to outsource things to other people
that you would consider to be representative
of yourself or your brand or in some way could
be potentially damaging?
I think about, this has been a hard one for
me because anytime an app ships or anytime
anything happens that is associated with a
company that I have started, if there's something
breaks or it's not done the correct way, it's
always like, "Oh, Kevin, why didn't you catch
this?"
Blah blah?
And I'm like, "I did, there's 15 other people…"
Tim Ferriss: That's what other people say
to you, or that's what you say to you?
Kevin Rose: Both.
They somehow think I'm doing everything.
And so they'll be like, "It's impossible that
you didn't catch this."
And I'm like, "I didn't see it before it went
out."
And so I'm wondering, because your brand is
so important to protect, who has final edit
on your podcast?
How did you trust them with that?
Because —
Tim Ferriss: Totally.
This is a great question.
Kevin Rose: Otherwise, you'd have to listen
to every single podcast you ever did in great
detail.
And it's like, yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, we've never talked about
this.
This is fun.
All right, I've never talked about this publicly,
so I am slow to give up the reins.
I'm very slow, and I'm slow to trust in general,
as you know.
There's some upside to that.
There are also a bunch of downsides.
But love it or hate it, that is where we are.
I'm very hypervigilant in that way.
In the case of the podcast, first step after
each podcast is recorded, before I even send
my edit notes or anything like that, is the
podcast is transcribed and there are some
great tools out there that can interact with
transcripts that we have also tested and used
in the past, like Descript.
Kevin Rose: We use Descript too.
Tim Ferriss: Right.
Which is really helpful.
For people who don't know, it allows you to,
say, strip out all the ums and ahs and filler
words automatically, and you make text edits
that then get translated into audio edits.
It's very interesting.
I also use professional sound editors and
so on, but step one for all of that is getting
the audio transcribed.
So we get the audio transcribed, and at this
point I have something like 700 episodes,
close to 700 episodes, which for those who
are wondering is, it's pretty crazy.
Next April, I think it's next April is going
to be 10 years of the podcast.
Can you fucking believe that?
It's crazy.
Kevin Rose: That's insane.
Tim Ferriss: 10 years, 1.4 episodes on average
per week, for 10 years straight.
That's insane.
Kevin Rose: Damn.
Did you have hair when you started?
I can't even remember.
I don't think.
Tim Ferriss: I probably had a little more
hair.
My hair probably looked like my beard right
now, so it wasn't much.
Kevin Rose: I definitely didn't have gray
hair.
I didn't have gray hair back then.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I wasn't going to be on
any of those poster boards where they show
you all the haircuts that are possible at
the barber.
It's very old school.
Go with the flat top, I want that one.
I wouldn't have been on any of those, but
I probably had a little more hair.
I was probably faking it.
I think I was probably at the last, the 11th
hour of my white-knuckling.
I probably had some cheesy faux hawk, because
that's all that was left and I was trying
to cover up bald spots.
Something like that.
In any case, the point I was going to make
is that my current general manager of the
podcast, who's really the COO of editorial,
has been working for me for seven or eight
years.
We've been working together a long time.
Over that period of time, we've now done a
few hundred episodes together, minimum, and
I started with making edits myself in a Google
Doc and then we would go back and forth.
Over time, I got to the point where I would
ask him to suggest edits and then I would
go through and provide refinements and feedback.
And I am at the point now where we probably
have 95 percent overlap, which is good enough.
And I therefore feel very comfortable with
letting him make the vast majority of edit
decisions related to the podcast.
Kevin Rose: That's awesome.
How long did that take you?
Was that a year process?
Tim Ferriss: At least a year.
Yeah, at least a year.
Because you're really training someone to
do two things.
One is to understand how you think well enough,
my decision-making process, so that they can
step into the shoes or into the mind of Tim
Ferriss to look at a transcript.
The second is to be the best version of their
editorial selves for using judgment, and it's
the combination that works really well.
So I would say it took me, probably in his
case, his responsibilities expanded dramatically
as we worked together over time.
But I would say since he has effectively run
the operation side of the podcast, probably
took a year and a half to two years is what
I would say.
And I think it can be done much more quickly
for people who really focus on it and who
don't have the trust issues that I have.
I think if you have a high enough volume of
podcasts, which I have directly throttled.
I used to do, say, at times, six, seven episodes
a month because you have all of these other
interview-based podcasts that are doing four
or five a week, and I felt like that was a
trend that I should — not a trend I should
follow, but that was certainly in my economic
best interest to publish more episodes and
people were consuming them.
But I started to drag my feet and realized
it was starting to feel like a J-O-B in the
sense that I really was not looking forward
to my conversations after the fourth or fifth
or sixth of a month.
So I dialed back deliberately so that I would
still enjoy what I was doing.
What that meant, though, is that you're getting
fewer iterations or you're getting fewer at-bat
practices with the person you're trying to
train to be a world-class editor.
And I think you could do it, if you had decent
volume, you could probably do it in three
months.
Especially, for instance, one thing that I
could have done, I just didn't think of it
and I didn't have really the bandwidth.
I'm just juggling a lot and it wasn't my absolute
top priority.
You don't have to use new audio.
I could have said, "Let's take the raw audio
from 20 episodes that were published before,"
or if you have a friend who's a podcaster,
you could have said, "Give me 20 of your episodes,"
and then have him run through it.
And then I would run through it, and boom,
before you know it, if the person is reasonably
adaptive and perceptive, they'll figure it
out.
So I would say three to six months, but I'm
at a point now where it's at least 95 percent
overlap.
And if there's something that's very nuanced
that I feel strongly about, I will still make
that edit myself.
And some of it is really, really, really,
really nuanced.
Let's just say a guest gives a long answer.
In the middle of that answer, they say something
that's factually incorrect.
And for my audience and also for the guest
themselves, I want to remove that.
But if I remove it, perhaps that removes a
bunch of important context.
So I may need to take something from elsewhere
in the conversation and slot it in or create
a hybrid sort of Frankenstein for it to make
sense, or ask them to do a pickup, meaning
record additional audio to slot in somewhere.
That is at a level of complexity and also
Tim Ferriss' subjective whim that I will often
step in to try to make some of those decisions.
But my right hand makes a lot of the decisions
on his own.
Kevin Rose: That's amazing.
Tim Ferriss: And it's incredible.
So that's been the process.
And there is, I will say, to put out a really
good finished episode, oftentimes there is
a fuck-ton of work that happens behind the
scenes, that if we do our jobs correctly,
are completely invisible.
Kevin Rose: For me, it's obviously a different
can of worms in running a startup in a business,
but I think of it kind of through this lens
where one just a hundred percent, not even
taking shortcuts when it comes to hiring.
Just hiring absolute A+ players, or what you
believe to be A+ players, from day one.
I really, when I was working at Google and
you walk in the door and you get to see who
you're surrounded by and who your peers are,
it's very apparent that that is, there's a
reason why their hiring process is so long,
and so kind of a little bit tedious, but just
it's quite the complex — several hurdles
that you have to get over before you actually
get in the door.
And I understand why those hurdles are so
high now, because once you get in, they give
you the keys to the castle and say, "Just
go run, make mistakes, learn," and they trust
you a lot.
And so for me, once we have — I know I have
high-quality talent to work with, it comes
down to if this were to go completely sideways,
how big of screw up would it be publicly into
our community?
And if the answer is a six or above, I probably
want to give it a little bit more hands-on
attention, and if the answer is an eight or
above, then I want to be heavily involved
in that process.
If it's a kind of five or below, who cares?
Let them make the mistake, because you just
don't have time to look at everything.
Tim Ferriss: Not only that, but you don't
want your employees, and look, I think you're
better at this —
Kevin Rose: The micromanaging side.
Tim Ferriss: Exactly.
Exactly.
It's like you don't want them to feel like
you're the teacher looking over their shoulder
to point out every mistake they make as they're
working, which has been hard for me to learn,
honestly, because I am such a perfectionist.
I don't know if I told you this.
Did I tell you that I was diagnosed with moderate/severe
OCD by a psychiatrist?
Did I tell you this?
Kevin Rose: No.
Holy shit.
That all makes sense now.
Tim Ferriss: What was funny is that I went
through this long thing, and then the psychiatrist
was like, "Okay, I feel like I have a very
confident read on our current state of play
and the diagnosis."
And so he tells me all this and he says, we're
on Zoom, and he's like, "I understand this
could be a lot to take in.
If you need time, we can take a break.
If you want to hop off the call and pick up
tomorrow…" and I was like, "Are you fucking
kidding me?
I'm not surprised at all."
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: I'm like, "Yeah, okay, fine.
What's next?
That's fine."
Kevin Rose: Dude, it's so funny you say that.
I've got an awesome new therapist that I'm
really enjoying.
She's amazing.
And she's like, "I want to refer you to someone
because what you're describing sounds like
ADHD."
And I'm like, "Yeah, no shit."
Big surprise.
Shocker.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, shocker.
Kevin Rose: It literally happened a week ago.
It's amazing.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
I reached out to a couple of my ex-girlfriends
who I'm friendly with, and I asked them, I
was like, "Does this square with your experience?"
And they're like, "Yeah, yeah.
It squares with my experience."
I was like, "Okay.
Confirmed."
And this was in, just to provide the context,
this was in the context of trying to determine
neuroanatomical targets for something referred
to as accelerated TMS, which I'm hoping to
talk quite a bit more about, but I don't feel
comfortable yet making any type of recommendation.
But it is a new protocol with a very, I shouldn't
say very old, but like 1980s-ish, forward
developing technology, transcranial magnetic
stimulation.
So it's brain stimulation for the purposes
of minimizing or eliminating the symptoms
of certain things like OCD, depression, generalized
— or maybe it's just general anxiety disorder.
I think it's generalized anxiety disorder.
GAD.
And I become very interested in this because
there are data related to something that's
been called the SAINT protocol, I think, that
had too many religious overtones so they abbreviated
to, I think maybe SNT.
It's a Stanford-based brain stimulation lab.
There's some incredible scientists involved,
including Nolan Williams, who's incredibly
impressive to me, who have developed this
protocol and the magnitude of effect that
I have seen in some of the data, this does
not apply to all people, it does not apply
to all conditions, but shows a magnitude of
effect that makes it equally as interesting
to me as psychedelic-assisted therapies.
It's the only thing I have come across in
the last five years that approaches the amplitude
of effect size that you see in some of these
results.
It's bananas, but it's very intense.
By accelerated TMS.
What that means is you are getting your brain
zapped, and it's not technically — I mean,
whatever.
We don't have to get into zapping.
It's using magnetism, but you fucking feel
it.
Let me make it very clear.
You are getting zapped for, and I could be
getting some of the specifics wrong, but I've
gone through one cycle of this already.
You're getting zapped for something like eight
and a half to 10 minutes every hour, on the
hour, for 10 hours a day, for five days straight.
So you're doing 50 sessions in five days,
and it's a hell of a thing.
But that is why I was undergoing a psychiatric
evaluation, was to determine what the diagnosis
was, such that they could try to determine
which coordinates to use, basically, in placement
of the stimulation.
Super, super, super, super interesting.
But the reason I brought that up is, winding
all the way back to kind of where we started,
I notice really — I notice really minute
details, and that means also every mistake.
I could scan document, I don't know if you're
like this, but I can look at a document that
four lawyers have reviewed and find stuff,
and I just have that ability.
I don't know what it is.
It's definitely not all blessing.
There's a lot of curse to that.
But it's like I can scan a document, reading
very quickly and be like, "This clause is
off.
That punctuation is off," in minutes.
Kevin Rose: Like a living ChatGPT.
Tim Ferriss: I'm kind of like, well, yeah,
or a Rain Man in some respects.
But that comes with a huge tax because it
drives other people crazy and you drive yourself
crazy.
And so I'm learning to contend with that,
which is a way of emphasizing how big a deal
it is for me to collaborate in the way that
I'm describing.
I will say also that the objective for the
creative offsite for me, was to try to create
a flywheel of collaborative potential, and
I'll explain what that means.
In other words, I wanted to create enough
imagery, enough artwork, also enough scaffolding
in terms of world building, so the mythologies,
the beliefs, the alliances, the conflicts,
the geography, such that I could take all
of that and give it as a world bible of sorts
to a writer who's never had any exposure to
the realm of Varlata, right?
The Legend of CØCKPUNCH, and they would be
equipped to write a short story, or a module,
or an adventure for D&D, a campaign, who knows,
or a comic book, and have it align with my
creative vision for that entire fantasy world,
which was a cool challenge.
I think it requires a little more time.
Those types of creative pushes are often two
to three weeks.
Three weeks seems to be the sweet spot.
That's a huge ask of my time and of everyone's
time, and I wanted to make sure that I felt
comfortable in a shorter format first.
But man, I'm excited, because what a lot of
people don't realize is this whole Legend
of CØCKPUNCH thing, the only thing I need
to do to make this something serious is change
the name.
I don't need to change anything about the
world.
Kevin Rose: Yes, I told you that.
Yes.
Tim Ferriss: It's actually really easy.
I think if I wanted to switch that gear, which
I think would be a terrible handicap right
now, because I want to continue to collaborate,
and by having the current branding, it alleviates
a lot of pressure I might apply to it.
There's very little I have to do to flip a
switch and make this a —
Kevin Rose: Will you do that?
Tim Ferriss: Extremely viable — I don't
know.
I don't know.
Maybe.
Kevin Rose: I think you should.
Tim Ferriss: Remember when we had this conversation?
Kevin Rose: I called you up and I said, "If
you do these three things, this shit's going
to take off."
And one of them was the name change.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, of course, of course.
I know it's a possibility.
Right now, it is working so well as a creative
hyperdrive and as a catalyst for just — it's
like having my own fusion reactor or something.
It's working so well that I'm like, "Look,
don't get too clever."
You can fuck things up by being too clever.
I was like, "Don't get too clever.
This is working really well.
You've lucked into a lot of it.
Some of it's by design, but you got really
lucky.
Ride the lightning for a while, don't fuck
it up."
So I'm going to stick with it for a while.
I don't feel also any time pressure whatsoever.
Kevin Rose: Can I ask you a question that
I hope you'll give me a more kind of vulnerable
response to?
Tim Ferriss: Oh, boy.
Kevin Rose: So, no, this is a good one though,
because from an outsider looking in, you say,
"Okay, Tim, you've told us," this is just
my observations.
You say over and over, "Legend of CØCKPUNCH.
It's a joke.
It's for fun.
It's a throwaway.
I'm having a good time.
Don't want to take it too seriously, blah,
blah, blah."
But in some sense, let me just think about
how to word this.
In some sense, if you did take it seriously,
now you're a, not a sci-fi, but you're a fiction
writer —
Tim Ferriss: A fantasy writer.
Kevin Rose: Fantasy writer.
And you could go for it.
You could decide at some point to go for it
and say, "I want to try this."
But there's also a sense that it could fail,
and you're protected right now from failure
because of the name.
So is that just a safety mechanism to keep
you from feeling failure, or — do you see
what I'm saying?
If we're being really vulnerable here?
Tim Ferriss: I do.
Yeah, it's a great question.
So here's what I would say.
It's actually in a sense the opposite for
me.
So it's not a throwaway, it's definitely not
a throwaway.
It is something I think, very profound, at
least for me personally, that is in the guise
of something ridiculous.
Which I think more people should try, honestly,
because it's actually a cheat code.
And I would say that instead of using it to
avoid the possibility of failure, what it
is enabling me to do is fucking swing for
the fences in ways that I would never dare
otherwise, that could result in just a complete
face plant.
So I'm actually risking many, many, many different
types of failure that I would be hugely averse
to otherwise, by couching it in the terms
that I've been using, and I am going to do
so much more of this in life.
Holy shit, this has been such an unlock for
me, that I'm going to do a lot more of it.
And I'll mention a few other things just quickly
because it ties into this.
That's the nature of The Random Show.
Let me just pull out a random piece of paper
from the hat and we'll go from there.
So there's a great book, it's actually excellent
for storytelling in general, although it is
comic specific.
It was recommended to me by a very good artist
and creative who works in comics named Daniel
Henriques, The DC Comics Guide to Writing
Comics, which is such a boring title for a
really entertaining and useful book.
But The DC Comics Guide to Writing Comics
by Dennis O'Neil, it has sample scripts, it
shows you side by side script plus final output.
It goes into story arcs.
Not all of it would apply to what I want to
do, but it was — I found it incredibly useful
and also hilarious.
The writing itself is spectacular.
I thought it was spectacular.
By Dennis O'Neil.
So I want to give a hats off to him.
And in terms of fiction, I would be very insecure
if I were to take fiction writing, prose only
on, in, say, novel or book form, because there
are some people who are so, so good at it.
For people out there who have not read any,
say fantasy fiction, we could certainly get
into science fiction.
I'm a huge fan of science fiction.
Ted Chiang.
I'll just say that.
C-H-I-A-N-G.
The collection's just short stories if you
want something —
Kevin Rose: Oh, it's got like eight short
stories or something like that in one book?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, exactly.
Kevin Rose: That was really good.
You said that a couple of years ago, you recommended
that.
I read it.
Fantastic.
Tim Ferriss: I mean, he's absurdly, absurdly
good.
The movie Arrival —
Kevin Rose: So good.
Tim Ferriss: Was based on one of his short
stories.
I mean, the guy is so, so fantastic.
Kevin Rose: To be able to pack that much information,
like that dense of storytelling, in such a
short little — it brings you in so quickly.
It's unbelievable.
Tim Ferriss: His ability to turn your brain
inside out with new concepts in a short story
is —
Kevin Rose: In 15 pages.
Tim Ferriss: Unbelievable.
It's unbelievable.
So Ted Chiang for science fiction would be
my starting point.
And then you can try the longer stuff.
But for fantasy, if people — Lord of the
Rings is just too much for people to chew
on, generally.
The Name of the Wind by Patrick Rothfuss.
I think Darya has read that actually, because
I recommended it —
Kevin Rose: She's read almost all sci-fi.
Tim Ferriss: She read The Graveyard Book,
which was usually my — The Graveyard Book
by Neil Gaiman is usually my, what would you
call it?
My trainer for people who are non-fiction
purists who are like, "Fiction is dumb.
I don't want to read fiction."
I'll usually break them in with The Graveyard
Book by Neil Gaiman.
Usually audiobook, because these people are
like, "I'm fucking busy."
I'm like, "Okay, fine.
Well, listen while you're walking the dog
or doing the dishes or whatever."
The Graveyard Book, read by Neil Gaiman — the
ensemble is great, but don't do the ensemble
cast — read by Neil Gaiman.
And then the other one is The Name of The
Wind by Patrick Rothfuss, which is fucking
incredible.
And I recommended it to a friend.
I hadn't read it in 10 years or something.
And my friend, who is a fucking snob when
it comes to writing, he has very high standards,
he reads excellent books.
And he ripped through the two books that are
part of this series, The Kingkiller Chronicle,
in like four days.
These are long books.
And it completely blew his mind, which got
me very excited to read more fiction.
But I didn't have a good lead until these
concept artists, at least I think one of the
concept artists and one of the writers at
least, it was like three out of five or something,
said, "You have to read The Blade Itself by
Joe Abercrombie."
And I'm in the middle of listening to The
Blade Itself by Joe Abercrombie, and it is
really fun.
It is really, really, really good.
I've really been enjoying it.
So on the creative side, I'm soaking myself
in masters of fiction, but I don't have the
balls yet, or let me put it a different way.
It's not a balls issue.
I don't have the hubris to want to take that
on right now.
I realize I have a lot of skill development
to focus on, and I think that my sweet spot
will actually be potentially comics.
I really think comics might be my sweet spot.
Kevin Rose: That would be awesome.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, because I have the visual
sensibility.
I mean, I do have the directorial visual capacity.
I can think about all of that very easily.
So I could see you really, really enjoying
that.
And I want to recommend one other thing, which
is there's a very short, it's not really a
TED Talk, but it's on TED.
There's a nine-minute monologue.
And what's genius about it is that he's such
a good actor that he makes it seem impromptu,
but you know he rehearsed the shit out of
it.
It takes a lot of practice to make something
seem like it's impromptu.
And it's Ethan Hawk, the actor, and it is
a short TED Talk.
It's like nine minutes long called “Give
Yourself Permission to Be Creative.”
And holy shit, it is so good and so powerful.
I really, really recommend everybody check
it out.
Kevin Rose: I'm writing it down right now.
Tim Ferriss: It's such an easy lift.
Kevin Rose: Amazing.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Speaking of TED Talks, thank you for coming
to my TED Talk.
Kevin, you're up.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, so one thing I wanted to
— we talked about that brain stimulation
stuff, and Adam Gazzaley, our mutual friend
at UCSF, has been experimenting with some
of that stuff as well.
Tim Ferriss: For a long time.
For a long time.
He's one of the pros.
Kevin Rose: Long time.
One thing that I will say, our mutual friend,
Matt Walker, who runs the Berkeley Sleep Lab,
have you talked to Matt about brain stimulation
at all?
Tim Ferriss: No.
You know, God, what a fucking — I'm really
on my Long Island self right now.
My F-bombs are at a high density for this
episode.
I literally took a note like 10 minutes ago
to catch up with Matt Walker, because I haven't
caught up with him in a while.
So yes, I've been thinking about that.
Kevin Rose: Probably one of the nicest nicest
humans on Earth.
Tim Ferriss: Such a sweet guy, but I haven't
talked to him about brain stim.
I have not.
Kevin Rose: Matt is, and this is by no means
an ad, I'm not involved at all, he's a scientific
advisor for a company called Somnee, S-O-M-N-E-E.
He sent me one of the devices.
I haven't tried it yet, but I have it sitting
next to my bed, oddly enough, as one does.
But you wear it 15 minutes before you go to
sleep, and it's supposed to just really improve
your sleep quality through, via brain stimulation.
So definitely check that out.
And I know that obviously he wouldn't sign
on to something unless he believed the science
was solid, and he was very excited about this.
It's a tough hurdle as a startup to get people
to feel comfortable stimulating their brain
with currents.
It's challenging, but it's really promising.
And Matt was impressed with the result.
Tim Ferriss: That's amazing.
Kevin Rose: So if you have trouble with sleep,
definitely check it out.
And Matt's obviously a legend.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, my God.
Story of my life.
Good lord.
Yeah.
So I will talk to Matt.
He is genuinely such a brilliant, but moreover,
sweet guy.
He's just one of the sweetest guys I've ever
met.
Kevin Rose: Oh, he's nice.
I kind of want to write him into my will and
have him watch my kids if I die.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, seriously.
"I know I met you a year ago, but can you
be the godfather to my unborn children, please?"
Kevin Rose: "You've never met them, but…"
Tim Ferriss: Exactly.
He is the sweetest guy.
Such a sweet guy.
All right, so I know you have a bunch of stuff.
What else are you holding back here?
Kevin Rose: Speaking of just crazy shit early
that I want to tell you about, I think about,
well, technology startups in general, we all
know 90 percent of them fail.
Some of them are so odd they're worth mentioning
because if they become something larger, you'll
want to have heard about it.
This is one of those.
So there is a site out there, it is called
friend.tech.
Have you heard of this?
Tim Ferriss: No.
Kevin Rose: Okay.
Tim Ferriss: I don't think so.
Kevin Rose: So you get a signup code, they're
posting them all over Twitter, somebody you'll
know will have one.
And when you go in, what they have realized,
and what Apple has done, is Apple has said,
"You must pay us a 20 percent tax on all transactions."
And they've also banned cryptocurrency trading
from the App Store.
They don't allow that to happen.
They like to have wallets and they allow you
to buy from Coinbase, but as payments, they
haven't yet enabled that.
So some clever individuals have figured out
that they, back in the day, they have a way
with Safari, the little browser built into
the iPhone, to install apps on the phone that
aren't actually from the App Store.
Tim Ferriss: That's wild.
Okay.
I see where this is going.
Kevin Rose: Okay.
So what they've done is, somebody created
something called friend.tech.
And when you sign in with your Twitter and
off with your Twitter, it creates a profile
for you.
It gives you a place to post to your followers.
You can post out and they can all respond
back, but they can't see each other's responses.
So it's almost like a private DM that is coming
from them to you.
But whenever you send something out, it goes
to everyone.
Now, what happens though, is you get one share
of yourself to begin with, and they call them
keys now because they realize the SEC might
freak out about that.
And they're tokenizing humans via a bonding
curve.
Tim Ferriss: What?
What does that mean?
Kevin Rose: That means, think of bonding curves
like a slippery slide, like a child's slide.
And if you had to place a toy car on the bottom
of the slide, if you're early and you're the
first one, you're buying in at the ground
floor, but as the car starts to go up the
slide, which is the predefined curvature of
the bonding curve, it becomes more and more
pricey.
So if I buy Tim Ferriss as user number one,
I might pay 10 cents a share for Tim Feriss,
and the next person might pay 15 cents, the
next person might pay 20, and then it goes
up from there.
It's all done in Ethereum, but they do it
on a layer two, which is another complex way
of saying they kind of take it off chain,
or not on the main chain, so that it only
costs pennies to do these transactions.
Tim Ferriss: So you're dodging Apple and you're
dodging the gas fees.
Kevin Rose: Right.
So think of this, imagine this as a new type
of OnlyFans, but for everyday content.
So if Twitter can have subscriptions, OnlyFans
can have fetishes about whatever.
I don't even want to name any because I've
seen some weird shit, I've heard about some
weird shit.
Tim Ferriss: Nice save, nice save.
Kevin Rose: Thank you, thank you.
So this allows them to dodge the micropayments,
and it is more or less — and so I signed
up, I was like, "What the hell?
I'm just going to try this."
But here's the crazy thing, Tim, as people
buy and sell you, a percentage that goes back
to you as the creator, the content creator.
So I didn't know that going into this.
I'm like, "Oh, I'm just going to buy and sell
some of my friends."
And so I haven't sold anybody yet.
I just bought.
Tim Ferriss: Wait, hold on.
When you're saying buy and sell some of your
friends, or you're selling — not shares,
because SEC will freak out, but whatever the
hell —
Kevin Rose: They call them keys.
Tim Ferriss: Keys.
Keys in yourself, what do people get?
Okay, so they pay for this thing?
Kevin Rose: Access to your feed.
They get access to your feed.
Tim Ferriss: All right.
Kevin Rose: So if you signed up —
Tim Ferriss: So it's like an Ethereum-denominated
Patreon in a way.
Something like that?
Kevin Rose: Yes, exactly.
But it's based on a bonding curve, so the
sooner you get in the better.
And then there's, as you exit down, it follows
the same curve down.
So as you sell shares, so Nadya from Pussy
Riot, I paid for hers, and she posts some
things on her feed.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, that's very nice.
Kevin Rose: Nadya's a beautiful woman.
There's no doubt about that.
Tim Ferriss: Kevin just showed his iPhone
screen to the video for those who want to
check out the video.
The video version.
Kevin Rose: Hey, listen, Darya likes her.
She told Darya that she has a nice ass.
So my wife is okay with her.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, wow.
Kevin Rose: I don't even know if I should
be bringing this up right now.
I've had two glasses of wine.
Tim Ferriss: Female politics are so next level.
Kevin Rose: So next level.
Tim Ferriss: Dudes are just playing checkers
and women are playing 3D chess, it's so much
more complicated.
Kevin Rose: I know.
She goes to Darya like, "Oh, you have a really
nice ass."
And Darya's like, "Thank you."
And then later Darya's like, “Oh, she said
I have a really nice ass.”
I'm like, what do I say?
"Oh, you both have nice asses."
What am I supposed to say?
There's nothing you can say to win.
Tim Ferriss: You're like, "I like food, I
like ass.
I would like some scrambled eggs."
Kevin Rose: Now there's nothing you can say.
You're going to go back to your own program.
So anyway, she's a fun one to follow.
But here's the funny thing is people are buying
or selling me, and I wasn't aware of this,
you get a cut of it.
So dude, I've got almost three ETH in just
royalties from people buying and selling me
on this.
Tim Ferriss: So here's what I'm guessing.
The people who are at the bottom of the slide
are marking up and then selling their shares,
their keys.
Kevin Rose: Potentially.
Tim Ferriss: And Kevin, so let me ask you
this.
Are you ending up with the same scumbags that
are so common in Web3 land, or is it something
you don't have to deal with?
Kevin Rose: Scumbags?
I call them friends, but I would say that
I don't —
Tim Ferriss: I'm not saying everybody in those
communities fits the description of scumbags,
but there are a lot of fucking idiots, let's
be honest.
Kevin Rose: I don't think you can block anyone
here, but so far everyone has been super nice.
I only have 38 holders.
Tim Ferriss: Well, also because if it's a
DM, they don't get any social reinforcement
for being pricks, right?
Kevin Rose: Right.
Tim Ferriss: That just removes —
Kevin Rose: Yes, exactly.
But my point really is not so much about whether
this is, I think the SEC comes in here at
some point if this gets too big and it's like,
this probably isn't right, but there's something
interesting about this idea of owning a portion
of — it's like when we were kids and you
said, "Hey, this band's going to be huge."
And you listen to a band —
Tim Ferriss: You get rewarded for being early.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, exactly.
And you were like, "No, trust me.
Trust me, they're going to break out.
This song is just the beginning."
And then they become the next Pearl Jam or
whatever, and you're like, "I told you, man.
I was early.
I was a fan since day one."
This is a way to say I was a fan since day
one and get rewarded for it at the same time.
So it's a fascinating social experiment.
I don't know where it's going to go, but I
think it's worth people just kicking the tires
on it.
Tim Ferriss: And so the way you get rewarded,
then if you're buying keys, God, that's awkward.
That term is used for so many things, but
whatever, keys in someone.
So I buy keys in Kevin Rose.
The way I get rewarded is number one, access
to the feed.
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Although I don't think your ass
shots are going to be as good as the one that
you just showed me.
Kevin Rose: No, but I have pictures of you
that I haven't exposed yet that I might post
tomorrow.
Tim Ferriss: All right, perfect.
Can't wait.
And then secondly, the way you get rewarded
is you can, I guess, sell some or all of your
keys if you got in early.
Kevin Rose: You get one share of your own
self.
You can buy more shares of your own self if
you're bullish on yourself.
But I would not recommend going and selling
yourself.
That just looks odd.
For me, I've just gone out and bought a handful
of other people that I respect or want to
see their content.
And I haven't sold anybody because I think
this is like a house of cards a little bit,
but —
Tim Ferriss: Dude, what happened to your knuckles?
What is going on?
Kevin Rose: I was building a kid's construction
set, my kids' house, and fucked it up, my
middle knuckle.
Tim Ferriss: It looks like you've been punching
cement blocks.
Kevin Rose: I know.
I do want to take some boxing classes, though.
That's on my list of to-dos.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, you should.
Just don't get hit in the head.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, I know that.
Tim Ferriss: TBI does not help what you want
to do.
You could do — I mean, boxing's great.
You'll feel like you're about to die after
three minutes of working on pads.
It is so unbelievably tiring, especially if
you have a trainer who moves a lot and can
avoid what you're trying to accomplish.
Muay Thai, also excellent for pad work.
I've been thinking about getting back into
Muay Thai, but I have to fix my spinal pain
first.
And I mean, Muay Thai is probably one of the
worst things that I could possibly do right
now, given the state of affairs.
But boxing's great, man.
And you'll have access to a lot of good gyms.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, there's got to be some out
here.
I'm going to go try and find a good one.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, yeah.
Ton, ton.
You've got tons of options.
Just skip the sparring.
Skip the sparring and work on pads.
Kevin Rose: Well, you could do light sparring,
though, with padded headgear, as long as it's
not too —
Tim Ferriss: Let me explain what happens in
light sparring with headgear.
So here's what happens with light sparring
with headgear.
Everyone's cool for like 60 seconds —
Kevin Rose: Till you’re not?
Tim Ferriss: — And then someone throws a
punch that's a little too hard and they say,
"Oh, sorry, man, sorry."
And the other person's like, "Yeah, that's
fine.
No problem."
And then the other person throws a shot, it's
a little harder.
And then before you know it, you're just fucking
giving each other brain damage left and right.
And then you both have a headache for three
days.
And you actually have real jobs, and it's
complete waste of brain cells.
So the way that sparring, it's not really
sparring, but the way that contact can make
sense is if you have someone who's really
good at holding mitts, pads, who will occasionally
check you with their own hands, but they have
the pads on.
So they're not hitting you hard, but they're
giving you the feedback —
Kevin Rose: Just a little snap to the face.
Tim Ferriss: So you have to react and you
have to develop some defensive capabilities.
I think that's tolerable.
But speaking as someone, oh, my God, going
through these psychiatric evaluations, the
number of questions related to concussions
and traumatic brain injury is really beyond
anything I would've expected.
Like the correlation of depression, anxiety,
et cetera, to TBI, to traumatic brain injury
is undeniable.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, it turns out fucking up
your brain is going to fuck up your brain,
as it comes.
Tim Ferriss: Well, yeah, but it's not immediately
clear if you're, say, a skateboarder when
you're a kid.
I skateboarded.
You did too.
I'm sure you ate shit sometimes, like you
whacked the living hell out of your head.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, I was actually talking to
Tony Hawk about this because his mom passed
from dementia.
And we were talking about some of the brain
injuries and stuff that he's been through.
At the time, this was years ago, so I'm kind
of paraphrasing, but at the time he was just
like, "It's what I do."
He's like, "You're kind of too far in at that
point."
And I talked to Rhonda Patrick and I was like,
this is many years ago, we were talking about
omega-3s to get for Tony and just stuff that
we could potentially do to give him some brain
health.
It's tough.
He's seen some damage.
Have you ever seen his chins?
Tim Ferriss: Oh, they must be terrible.
I haven't.
Kevin Rose: They're beat up, dude.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, he's like a Muay Thai fighter.
Kevin Rose: Dude, I have so much respect for
that dude.
I mean, talk about somebody that, the last
time I saw him was probably six months ago
and we went to this donut place that was opening
up.
And he had a cane with him.
Tim Ferriss: What?
A cane?
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
Well, he had just had surgery.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, I see.
Kevin Rose: And I'm like, "How are you doing,
man?"
He is like, "Ah, you know.
"They just opened me up, put a few more screws
in."
He's like, "I'll be skating."
It is like, the dude just has no fear.
He's just like, "Ah, they just opened me up,
put a few screws in and I'm going to go back
at it."
What the fuck, dude?
Tim Ferriss: Good for him.
Kevin Rose: You're already the G.O.A.T.
You know what I mean?
Tim Ferriss: I mean, Laird Hamilton, same
with surfing, right?
He's just like, "Yeah, get patched up.
I'm back out there."
Kevin Rose: That's just insane.
Tim Ferriss: Like, "Broke my leg on a hundred-foot
wave in 17 places.
Yeah, it's fine.
They'll just stitch it back together.
I'll be out in two months."
Kevin Rose: It's just insane, dude.
I'm not built like that.
It's impressive.
Tim Ferriss: Side note, and this is not to
make a blanket recommendation because that
would be really irresponsible.
But I saw a presentation, I'm not sure if
it's publicly available, on a scientific study
that examined psilocybin, what is considered
the active component —
Kevin Rose: Everybody knows what that is!
Tim Ferriss: Some do.
Some do.
In psilocybe mushrooms or different types
of mushrooms, so magic mushrooms, in Parkinson's
patients for the minimizing or reversal of
symptoms.
And it's very compelling.
So I do think that psychedelics, it's unclear
exactly what type, to me at least, maybe they
are the tryptamine psychedelics.
Who knows?
Maybe it has something to do with the serotonin
type 2A receptors.
I'm not sure.
That's beyond my pay grade.
But I will say that, for those who are interested,
if they can find this research, which could
be very preliminary, who knows?
Maybe it's kind of pilot study type of status.
But looking at psilocybin as applied to Parkinson's
patients.
I do think, from a neurogenesis perspective,
I find it one of the more promising avenues
of exploration.
For people with TBI, I do think psychedelic-assisted
therapies are very interesting.
I would say psilocybin is probably one of
the better-researched molecules and worth
investigating.
Ibogaine, also very interesting.
But it has cardiac implications.
Kevin Rose: It stops your heart.
Tim Ferriss: There are cardiac implications.
Nolan Williams, I mentioned earlier, has looked
at ways to mitigate some of the cardiac risk.
Both of those are very, very, very interesting.
Psilocybin, at this point, probably being
the more versatile of the two just from a
safety profile perspective.
But I'm very optimistic.
For those people who want to look at the edges
of scientific inquiry, I'm very optimistic
actually, in a way that I wasn't, say, 10
years ago in how we might contend with neurocognitive
decline or neurodegenerative disease.
I'm actually much more optimistic than I was
10 years ago.
Kevin Rose: Did you happen to invest in Paul
Stamets' new company?
Tim Ferriss: I did not.
I'm not doing a whole lot of investing and
I haven't.
Kevin Rose: We did at True Ventures.
Tim Ferriss: You did?
Good.
Kevin Rose: He's got a psilocybin new company
that they're doing studies.
And hopefully, when this stuff gets legalized,
we'll see what happens.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, Paul Stamets knows this
stuff, man.
Paul Stamets, he's one of a kind.
He's a great human being in my experience,
all my experiences with him.
We actually, just last week, maybe in the
last two weeks, he and I did a challenge grant
to raise money for the Amazon conservation
team to buy a historically indigenous land
to return it to certain tribes in Colombia,
including the Kogi and a handful of others.
They're not in the Amazon, they're at higher
altitude in the north, and a handful of others.
And then ACT equips them with training to
be able to sort of monitor and report on their
territory, because it's not really enough
just to secure land rights.
And Paul was generous enough, along with my
foundation, to issue the challenge grant.
So we just did that together in the last two
weeks.
Paul knows his stuff.
He really, really knows his stuff.
I feel very confident in saying that.
Smart guy.
Kevin Rose: He's got some great TED talks
as well, worth checking out.
All right, should we move on?
Tim Ferriss: Let's move on.
So I'll mention something that's sitting outside,
I can see it from here, that people might
be interested in.
So I've been and still am a fervent believer
in cold therapy.
So using ice baths as a means of controlling
inflammation, as a means of mood elevation
that lasts —
Kevin Rose: Yeah, mood elevation, big time.
Tim Ferriss: It's unbelievable.
And generally, my approach has been to get
a chest freezer of some type and fill it with
ice, et cetera.
And that works, but they get really disgusting
really quickly.
Kevin Rose: They all do, dude.
I bought one of the machines, the real pro
ones.
Tim Ferriss: Yes.
And then you're stuck with this thing that
is an eyesore and you don't know what to do
with it.
Kevin Rose: You can't move it.
I tried to sell it.
I couldn't.
Tim Ferriss: So I ended up, because I realized
how significant a lever this is for improving
my quality of life just on a daily basis — and
I'll backstep for a second and just say one
thing that I learned from Tony Robbins, to
give him credit, and I don't know if he came
up with this, but is the sequence of state,
story, strategy.
So it's like, fix your state first.
Only then can you come up with an enabling
story, and only then can you come up with
an effective strategy.
Because if you're feeling shitty and you're
sleep-deprived and you're kind of depressed
or anxious or whatever, you try to come up
with a strategy, meaning, how to fix something,
you're not going to come up with a good strategy,
generally speaking.
So it's like, fix your physical state first,
then you can come up with an enabling story,
then come up with an effective strategy.
So the state piece is very important.
There aren't that many ways I have found to
change state.
Exercise is one, but it requires generally
a fair amount of time.
Heat is also effective, but again, generally
requires, say, it doesn't sound like much,
but it's like 15 to 30 minutes, let's just
say, in a sauna.
It's very effective.
Cold is the fastest.
It's just the fastest for me.
And I've gone without cold therapy because
I've not wanted to get some huge chest freezer
or a pro model.
I am also going to be getting a pro model.
Kevin Rose: They get all scummy though, and
then you've got to put chlorine in them and
it's a lot.
Tim Ferriss: But I went on Amazon and I found
something called the Cold Pod, which you set
up in like five minutes.
You fill it with water from a hose, you put
ice in and it works perfectly well as a cold
plunge.
Kevin Rose: Is it like a little body wrap?
Tim Ferriss: And I ended up buying a Yeti
cooler to store ice in.
So I have a few days of ice.
And it's, let's see, what would it be?
It would be like if you were standing, maybe
it's hip height and it's probably three feet
in diameter.
And you get in, you just kind of crouch in
there and it works fucking great.
It works really well — and it costs like
150 or 200 bucks maybe.
I don't know.
Maybe it's a hundred bucks.
It's not crazy.
Kevin Rose: 169.
Tim Ferriss: There you go.
And I've been really impressed with this thing.
It's very basic.
And even when it's been very hot outside,
you put in two bags of ice and you let it
sit for 20 minutes, it's going to get pretty
cold.
It's not going to be 30 degrees, but it's
probably going to be mid-fifties, depending
on how much water you have in there.
Pro tip, the more water you have in there,
the more ice you're going to need to cool
it.
So don't fill it all the way up to the top,
fill it up like halfway and then add the ice.
And it's been a game changer for me.
Kevin Rose: This is a plastic trash can, dude.
Tim Ferriss: Well, no, it's not a plastic
trash can.
Kevin Rose: I mean, props to whoever made
this shit because it probably cost them like
15 bucks to build one of these things.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, it's not a trash can, just
to be clear.
Look, we're not talking about a fucking Maserati.
But here's what's nice about it.
It's very easy to set up.
It is not a trash can because that makes it
sound like it's like mid-chest height and
hard.
It's easy to pack.
You can actually travel with it, if you want
to travel with it.
I would just say with people who have —
Kevin Rose: How do you travel with it?
Tim Ferriss: Oh, it's super easy, man.
Kevin Rose: Oh, it folds up?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, it folds up.
You can stick it in the bag and take it with
you.
It's super easy.
Kevin Rose: To your hotel room.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, the hotel loves 50 gallons
of water spilling out.
So for those people who have perhaps heard
about the benefits of cold therapy but have
avoided it because it's too expensive, it's
too time-consuming, whatever.
This is a way to test it.
And I would just say this is a low hurdle
way to test it out.
And I used it earlier today, it’s fantastic,
changed my day.
So that's the Cold Pod.
And there are a bunch of other options that
look basically identical.
I just went with the one with the best reviews.
Nothing fancy.
Kevin Rose: I need something like this because
I don't want to commit to sterilizing my water.
That's always been the problem with these
things.
I just want something I can get into.
But how many bags of ice do you really need
to pull this off?
Tim Ferriss: I'd have to go look at the bags
that are in the Yeti right now.
I mean you need —
Kevin Rose: Like six?
Tim Ferriss: No.
Well, it depends on the size of the bag, right?
I would say, I'm guessing, I have no idea
if this is accurate, two 20 pound bags of
ice probably.
So something like that, assuming that it is
about half full.
If you fill it up to the brim, you are making
a mistake because now to lower the temperature,
you're going to need a higher volume, a larger
volume of ice.
But if we're talking about, let's just say
it's halfway up and then you put in two 20
pound bags of ice, you're set.
So with a Yeti cooler and this thing, I am
good to go.
I’ve got a question for you, Kev.
Have you ever read poetry?
This is a hard left.
Kevin Rose: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah?
What do you read?
Kevin Rose: I shouldn't say it's poetry.
Tim Ferriss: It's tweets.
Kevin Rose: No, no, no.
Let me tell you, I'm going to send you the
book that I have found that I started reading
recently that was fantastic.
But I've dabbled.
Tim Ferriss: Horton Hears a Who?
Kevin Rose: No, no, no.
I've had a couple of books that I've picked
up, but they're mostly haiku books.
For me, haiku is kind of my poetry.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, sure.
It's sort of in the zone, right?
Kevin Rose: It's in the zone.
I like haiku because it really has to hit.
Don't fuck with me.
It really has to hit, though.
You know what I mean?
You've got three lines, you've got to pull
something pretty amazing.
Speaking of that sci-fi writer, it really
forces you to have something really dense
and trigger, make the mind leap in those three
lines, as they say.
Tim Ferriss: It's a strong constraint.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, for sure.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I was wondering because
I've been delving strongly back into poetry.
And that Ethan Hawke nine-minute TED Talk,
which is very informal, but don't let it fool
you, he prepared for it, the giving yourself
permission to be creative.
He talks about poetry and he mentions, and
I'm going to butcher this, but he says, "No
one really cares about poetry, or you wonder
why on Earth people would read poetry until
you have something happen.
It could be something tragic, like the death
of a parent.
It could be something incredibly joyous, like
the birth of a child.
And you wonder, has anyone ever felt this
way before?
How am I going to get through this?
Or how should I think about this?
And then poetry becomes really relevant or
it can become really relevant."
And I've been delving back into Mary Oliver.
I read her collection, Devotions.
And I recently bought a small collection called
Dream Work, which I haven't finished.
So in disclosure, if you read it and you hate
it, I'm not going to take the blame for it.
I also have reread now multiple times this
collection of newly translated Rumi, called
Gold, by Haleh Liza Gafori.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, Rumi's great.
Tim Ferriss: Who is particularly interesting
to me because she is a poet herself in English,
but she's also a native Farsi speaker.
So she can go back to the source material,
the original, and translate effectively.
And what many people don't realize is that
many versions of translated poetry are not
actually directly translated.
They take some earlier English translation
from the 1920s or something and then they
turn it into better poetry.
But now you have a leap from, say, Farsi to
English to English, which is like a game of
telephone, things get distorted.
Whereas she can go directly.
So Gold, this very short collection of Rumi
poetry, I've reread a number of times.
And this particular poet, I have not read
this yet, but you can see this, it says Time
Is a Mother by Ocean Vuong, V-U-O-N-G, which
I assume is Vietnamese.
I read his first book, which blew my mind.
I'm not sure why I was drawn to it.
I bought it as an impulse purchase at some
Barnes and Noble in New York City, and I think
it was probably the title.
The title was Night Sky with Exit Wounds,
which is a great fucking title.
It's so good.
And it had this family photo.
Kevin Rose: That's a great title.
I love a good title.
Tim Ferriss: Isn't it great?
And it was like a family photo on the front.
And I was like, what the fuck is going on
here?
So I picked it up.
And I will warn people in advance, trigger
warning for some people, there are some very
graphic sex scenes in this poetry book.
So there's that.
But I was so impressed.
I have not read his new collection yet, but
Night Sky with Exit Wounds, an apology to
the author if I'm butchering your name, I
was very impressed.
And what I loved about it also is that I'm
generally reading the words of dead poets,
generally.
Kevin Rose: Oh, my God, dude.
Tim Ferriss: Do you know what I mean?
I'm always reading the words of dead poets,
and this is a contemporary.
I would guess that this author is younger
than I am.
And it still put me into the cosmic philosophical
washing machine and fucked me up.
And I was like, okay, all right.
Kevin Rose: Can I give you a couple of recommendations
then, if you're into this?
Tim Ferriss: Yes.
Kevin Rose: There's a book called Japanese
Death Poems.
It's fantastic.
Tim Ferriss: I was gifted that by a friend
of mine who used to be Marine Force recon,
and it's fucking amazing.
Kevin Rose: Okay, awesome.
Tim Ferriss: How did you find that book?
Kevin Rose: There's haiku in there as well.
It was part of my whole discovery of haiku.
So that one is great.
Tim Ferriss: I know.
But how did you discover that?
I'm curious, before you get to the next one.
How did you find it?
Kevin Rose: I'll tell you how.
I read a book called Three Simple Lines, which
Henry Shukman, the Zen master that you've
had on the podcast, recommended to me.
And Natalie Goldberg is the author.
She was author of this book called Down the
Bones, I think it's called.
Tim Ferriss: Writing Down the Bones.
Writing Down the Bones.
Kevin Rose: That's right.
Tim Ferriss: That is a great book.
Great book.
Kevin Rose: She has a book called Three Simple
Lines, which is about haiku and it's fantastic.
It's a really good book.
That got me into haiku.
That got me excited about a bunch of other
of the greats like Basho and Buson, some of
the best Japanese haiku writers.
I bought a book called —
Tim Ferriss: The OGs.
Kevin Rose: OG Crew.
So I bought a book called The Sound of Water.
And then that led me to the Japanese Death
Poems.
And then there was one other one that I wanted
to tell you about that is really awesome,
which is, oh, here it is, I'm going to mess
up the Japanese pronunciation.
It's Chiyo-ni.
Are you familiar with it?
C-H-I-Y-O, Chiyo-ni, N-I.
Is that how you would say that?
Tim Ferriss: I don't know.
I'd have to look it up.
What is that?
Kevin Rose: So she is a Japanese woman haiku
master.
And so if you go and look up, basically, haiku
masters back in the day, this would probably
come as no surprise, were all men.
And so she's one of the very few that was
taken in and broke out and became a Japanese
haiku master.
And so it's just a really kind of awesome
story.
And you get some haiku from a female back
in those days, which is a long time ago.
Tim Ferriss: Super rare.
Kevin Rose: Super rare.
Yes.
Super rare.
Tim Ferriss: Super rare.
Yeah.
I am reading.
Okay, so I think it's Fukuda Chiyo-ni, so
that's her name, Fukuda.
Fukuda, which means, I guess, fortuitous rice
paddy, Fukuda Chiyo-ni.
Kevin Rose: That's amazing.
Tim Ferriss: It's like thousand era.
Ooh, my kanji are failing me right now.
Ni, I'm blanking on.
Was Japanese poet of the Edo period and a
Buddhist nun.
She's widely regarded as one of the greatest
poets of haiku, and then hokku, I don't know
what that is.
Some of Chiyo's best works include "The Morning
Glory," "Putting up My Hair," and "Again the
Women."
Fascinating.
Okay.
Yeah, I've not had any exposure to her.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, definitely worth picking
up.
I think it's out of print.
I was just looking right now.
Tim Ferriss: Holy shit.
She began writing haiku at seven, and by age
17 had become very popular all over Japan.
That's nuts.
Considering that she was born in 1703.
So to be born in 1703, and by 17, as a woman
in Japan, to be famous all over Japan, that's
bananas.
Kevin Rose: Right.
And I had seen some of her work in these other
books and it was just mind-blowing.
And I'm like, who is this woman?
And then I did, similar to what you did, probably
a year ago when I read the Wikipedia entry
or whatever and I was like, holy shit, she
was a badass.
Tim Ferriss: All right, I'll check it out.
So what was the name of the book, then, Chiyo-ni?
Is that it?
Kevin Rose: Yeah, it's Chiyo-ni: Woman Haiku
Master.
That's the one I purchased.
There could be others about her, but that
was the one that I had purchased, which is
probably just a compilation of her works.
Tim Ferriss: Cool.
So other books I'll throw out there for people
interested.
I recently listened to, I've been doing a
lot of audiobooks recently, Coyote America.
And I think the subtitle is, A Natural and
Supernatural History, which I believe is by
Dan Flores.
Yes.
Coyote America: A Natural and Supernatural
History.
And it's got 4.6 on Amazon, with more than
1,500 reviews.
And it's a biological, natural evolutionary
history of the coyote, but also a supernatural,
aka mythological, history of coyote and the
significance of coyote in different indigenous
traditions.
And it goes through the entire span of history.
Also drawing, most interestingly, I think,
parallels between the evolution and adaptation
of Homo sapiens and the evolution and adaptation
of coyotes.
Kevin Rose: This sounds horrible.
Tim Ferriss: It's uncanny.
Kevin Rose: It sounds horrible.
Tim Ferriss: It sounds horrible?
Kevin Rose: Okay.
Sorry.
You love coyotes.
Tim Ferriss: Wow, so judgy.
Kevin Rose: You love wolves.
Wolves are your [inaudible].
Tim Ferriss: No, coyotes would be first, probably,
wolves would be second.
Kevin Rose: What's the one in the mouth?
Tim Ferriss: Those were wolves.
When I spent time with arctic wolves, I mean
gray wolves, but from Canada.
Kevin Rose: That's crazy.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, on the teeth.
That's the greeting.
Yeah.
By the way, folks who may wonder, wolf head,
not the same as a dog head.
They're fucking humongous.
They can put your entire head in their mouths.
They are not the same as dogs.
But I would identify more with coyote.
And it's a fascinating history to recognize
how adaptive both humans, in the sense of
Homo sapiens, and coyotes have been over time.
I mean, humans attempted the most systematic
extermination of coyotes as a species unlike
any other species in the history of humankind.
I mean, we're talking about millions upon
millions upon millions of poison bait traps
and so on set.
And despite that, coyotes have proliferated
and adapted beyond anyone's wildest imaginations.
Now, part of that is from the removal of their
check and balance, which is gray wolves.
So there's the removal of the gray wolf as
the apex predator, which then has resulted,
in part, in this proliferation of coyote populations.
But because they were never the top predator,
they have a wariness and caution about them
that makes them very hard to kill.
Furthermore, when they're under pressure,
their litter size increases, isn't that wild,
as an evolutionary adaptation?
When they're under threat, they go from having,
I'm making this up, but let's just say three
pups per litter to six or seven pups per litter.
Kevin Rose: Oh, crazy.
Tim Ferriss: Isn't that wild?
Kevin Rose: It is wild.
Tim Ferriss: It's a fascinating book.
It's really, really interesting.
And also interesting from the lens of looking
at how we have historically looked at coyotes
as a reflection of the aspects of ourselves
that we were least willing to accept.
Super interesting.
Going all the way back to Mark Twain.
I love Mark Twain, however, on the particular
account of coyotes, created a whole ton of
fucking damage and craziness.
But it was a good book.
It was a good book.
Especially the first half, I would say.
Kevin Rose: You know what I wish there was?
This is just me being a random two glass and
a half in —
Tim Ferriss: It’s The Random Show.
Kevin Rose: It’s The Random Show.
You know what'd be fun?
I'm just making this up.
I like product ideas.
Wouldn't it be cool if you could say, "Hey,
I'm Tim.
At 7:00 p.m. tonight I'm going to listen to
this coyote book for an hour.
And we could all tune in and listen at the
same time and see comments and chat and stuff
like that.
And there would be no voice.
It wouldn't be disruptive.
We're just all listening.
And it would be like, you could say one thing
per five minutes or whatever, or give a heart
or something when you'd like a certain segment
of it or something.
There'd be something pretty powerful about
that.
Tim Ferriss: That would be super fun.
I think people would really dig that.
Kevin Rose: Especially if you were kind of
listening at the same time.
It's like, oh, I'm listening with Tim right
now.
Tim Ferriss: I love that idea.
I love that idea.
Kevin Rose: Right.
If anybody from Audible's out there.
Tim Ferriss: Being synchronous and connected
in that way.
Kevin Rose: Dude, tech, it's amazing.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, that's not what I was going
to say.
I mean, it is amazing.
Amazingly good and amazingly bad.
I mean, we are more connected than we have
ever been in terms of communication, and more
isolated and lonely than we have ever been.
Holy shit.
What a situation.
Kevin Rose: Good point.
All right, let's get through — we're an
hour and a half in, but I've got some crazy
shit to tell you still.
Can I get through —
Tim Ferriss: Well, let's go to crazy town.
Come on, Kevin Rose has been holding out.
Kevin Rose: You and I have been supplement
geeks for a while, you more so than me for
many, many years.
You got me onto some crazy shit early on.
I always give credit back to the Tim Feriss
for the earliest — you got me into everything,
man.
All the HGH and stuff, then you were shooting
me up with the tests and —
Tim Ferriss: Fecal matter transplants from
Tasmania.
Kevin Rose: Fecal matter transplants.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
All the ketamine suppositories.
Kevin Rose: Just the best.
I mean, I just did one before we started the
show, so feeling it.
All right, so a few things.
Is that a thing, by the way?
Do people put ketamine up their butt?
Tim Ferriss: Oh, yeah.
They boof the K up the bung.
Kevin Rose: Do they?
Tim Ferriss: It's a thing.
It's a thing.
Yeah.
I think it's ridiculous, but —
Kevin Rose: It's fast.
Tim Ferriss: — people like any excuse to
take drugs up the bung.
Kevin Rose: Put stuff up their butt.
Tim Ferriss: This is also a constant through
human history.
Yeah, go figure that one out.
Kevin Rose: Do you have a book about it and
coyotes?
Tim Ferriss: The 4-Hour Coyote Suppository?
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
All right.
Tim Ferriss: I don't really want the coyote
up the bung.
That sounds uncomfortable.
Kevin Rose: It does.
Let's go straight into supplements.
Tim Ferriss: For everybody involved.
Kevin Rose: A few of the things that I wanted
to mention were — you've cut back on supplements,
is that fair to say, over the years?
When I went to your medicine cabinet one time,
there was a thousand things in there.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
I mean, less than I used to, for sure.
I mean, I still take more supplements than
anyone else I know, except for maybe Peter.
Kevin Rose: You tell me how many of these
you agree with or you take or you're curious
about.
Okay?
Number one, I have found that collagen for
us getting older, is legit, in terms of reducing
visible lines, just general skin health.
Tim Ferriss: You're doing great.
Kevin Rose: I know.
Come on.
Do you take collagen?
Tim Ferriss: This is going to sound funny.
Collagen makes me itchy.
I don't know why.
Kevin Rose: Does it?
Tim Ferriss: I get itchy.
Yeah, so I do take collagen.
I think it's very interesting also, as a flooding
dose, prior to resistance training, and people
can look this up.
Taking collagen prior to stimulating, say,
a location of injury, is very, very interesting.
It is interesting.
Yeah.
Kevin Rose: I used to have left —
Tim Ferriss: But, I hate being really fucking
itchy, so I don't take it too much.
Kevin Rose: So, two things.
Rhonda Patrick puts together a great data
analysis of all the different published studies
that are out there, and there's really strong
evidence around just general skin elasticity,
as you get older.
And then, obviously, joints in general.
If you're running, any of that type of stuff,
just really healthy joint stuff.
Great Lakes, no affiliation, a brand that
Rhonda takes, I'm a fan of.
Okay, I'm just going to [inaudible].
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, your cheeks look like a
newborn's buttocks.
Is that from the collagen?
They look very voluptuous.
Kevin Rose: One other thing before we get
off the collagen train, bone broth.
Okay.
So Brodo, which you know Marco, right?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I do.
Kevin Rose: You've met him before.
Tim Ferriss: Of course I know Marco.
Kevin Rose: Okay, so Marco, James Beard award-winning
chef.
Best chef in New York City.
Tim Ferriss: Amazing.
He's been on my podcast.
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
Amazing guy.
Tim Ferriss: He's fantastic.
He's fantastic.
Kevin Rose: Here's the cool thing, is I talked
to him.
Brodo Forever was his broth company where
he shipped you frozen broth to your house.
And I used it all through COVID.
It was fantastic.
The best broth, kills everything on the shelves
that I've been a part of or I've tasted.
He figured out a way to get it so that he
doesn't have to add any preservatives, no
concentrates or nothing, but shelf-stable.
So it's fantastic.
And these are single servings.
You rip them up and put them in the cup and
just one minute in the microwave and you're
good to go.
It's my go-to broth.
Brodo is fantastic.
Brodo.com, no affiliation, not invested, just
a friend.
All right.
You ready for two more things?
Tim Ferriss: That's quite an inhale.
Kevin Rose: So I'll also mention, and this
is a little self-interested because I'm one
of the largest investors in this company.
So he's also played around with bone broth
from axis deer from Maui, which is from Maui
Nui Venison, which I'm very involved with.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, he has?
Kevin Rose: And the collagen and protein levels
are fucking bananas.
They're off the charts to the point where
people think there are errors in the lab reports.
It's really, really wild.
Tim Ferriss: Wow.
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Would they do pills of that?
Because that would be really interesting in
pill form.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, I don't think so.
Right now, it's just whole food or nothing,
which I kind of like, because it forces you
to do a little bit of work.
But Marco is the master of broth.
M-O-B.
Kevin Rose: He really is.
Tim Ferriss: He really is.
Yeah.
Try out Brodo, 100 percent.
Kevin Rose: If you live in New York, by the
way, he's got physical locations where you
can go and get these broths in cup form, like
if you're going to a cafe.
And you'll know — anyone in New York will
tell you it's the best.
It's just legit.
All right, a couple more things.
Three more things, real quick.
Aesop?
You know the brand Aesop?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
What is that?
Kevin Rose: They make little tiny baby hand
sanitizers now.
And they smell amazing.
Tim Ferriss: A-E-S-O-P?
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
Do you not know this brand?
Tim Ferriss: No, I do know the brand.
What are you using your hand sanitizer for?
Kevin Rose: No, just when you're in Ubers
and shit.
You've just got your little hand sanitizer.
Got kids.
Okay.
So I just want to throw that out there.
I have no affiliation.
Next thing is, creatine fucks up my stomach.
It really does.
Tim Ferriss: Gives you, yeah.
Potential for disaster pants high.
Kevin Rose: All kinds of things are wrong
with creatine.
But as someone that works out, you want to
take it because you get a little boost in
the gym and all that good stuff.
Kevin Rose: Have you ever tried this stuff
right here?
Tim Ferriss: Kre-Alkalyn, yeah.
I've got some in the bathroom.
Kevin Rose: Do you really?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I do.
Kevin Rose: It's buffered creatine.
Dude, it eliminated all my stomach issues.
Anyway, so it's done by NOW Sports.
If you had issues taking creatine and you're
working out and you want to take some, I just
want to throw it out there as something that
is good.
Tim Ferriss: You want to hear a horrifying
story that —
Kevin Rose: Oh, please.
Tim Ferriss: — I would never tell you if
I were sober?
Kevin Rose: Oh, of course.
Tim Ferriss: I was in San Francisco and I
was rushing to prepare for an international
flight, long international flight.
I can't remember where I was going, but it
was a long flight.
Kevin Rose: 12 plus hours, kind of deal.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
That kind of deal.
And I was running around, running around,
and I had two double espressos.
I had some espresso machine.
Kevin Rose: Uh-oh.
Tim Ferriss: I had two double espressos, a
bunch of magnesium —
Kevin Rose: Oh, I know where this is going.
Tim Ferriss: — and a whole shit ton of creatine.
Kevin Rose: Four grams, five grams?
What did you do?
Tim Ferriss: Some stupid amount.
Unnecessary amount.
And thought that was a good idea for whatever
reason.
And so I'm driving to the airport and I'm
like, "Oh, God, my stomach doesn't feel so
good."
And I'm like, "Oh, I'm kind of gassy.
Oh, not feeling so great."
And so I do a little lean, and just promptly
shit all over myself.
Kevin Rose: Oh, my God.
Tim Ferriss: So bad.
Kevin Rose: Are you in an Uber?
Tim Ferriss: No, no, I'm driving myself to
long-term parking.
And I'm like, "Okay."
And so I'm like, "Wow, this is a disaster.
What do I do here?"
Kevin Rose: You bust out the luggage.
Tim Ferriss: No, this is when I wish I had
your Aesop hand sanitizer.
And so I'm on my way and I'm just like, "All
right, how do I find the silver lining of
this?
This is so bad.
And I'm going to be late to my flight.
I might miss my flight."
And I call one of my close friends.
I'm not going to mention him by name, because
this is the one guy who's going to find this
funnier than anyone else.
So I call him and I'm like, "You'll not believe
what just happened."
And I explained the whole thing.
And of course, he gets extreme delight out
of this whole situation, which gives me some
redeeming aspect to the whole thing.
I get to the long-term parking garage and
I'm like, "What do I do here?"
So take off my underwear, wipe myself down
with my underwear, chuck it under some other
car, and run to my flight with no underwear
on, with long pants, obviously.
And then sit down for a 12-hour flight smelling
like I've just taken a tumble through a fucking
slaughterhouse.
Kevin Rose: Were you economy at that stage
of your career?
Tim Ferriss: Oh, yeah.
This was middle-seat economy for 12 hours,
kind of thing.
Kevin Rose: Oh, fuck.
Tim Ferriss: It was so bad.
I mean, it was bad for me.
It was embarrassing.
But it was bad also for everyone around me.
And I'm not proud of this, but I've had enough
Domaine Tempier to confess.
Kevin Rose: Everyone's had a close call, if
not a fatal disaster in this domain.
Tim Ferriss: If you've had enough creatine
and caffeine, don't lie to me.
You've had disaster pants at some point.
Either you saved it and you slid into home,
or you had absolute triage where it was a
disaster.
Kevin Rose: Tim, you mentioned Aesop for,
you wish you had some during this occasion.
Maybe they'll want to be a sponsor.
You could probably cut this little story out
and use it and be like, "I shit myself one
time and if I only had Aesop hand sanitizer,
the whole plane would've been happier."
Tim Ferriss: I think that'll be one of their
highest converting ads of all time.
Kevin Rose: Exactly.
Tim Ferriss: I have something to show you
as an artifact, physical artifact.
So this is the latest CØCKPUNCH Coffee, which
— it's very pretty.
Kevin Rose: Wow.
Tim Ferriss: It's very reflective and gorgeous.
Kevin Rose: That is beautiful.
That's a lot of CØCKPUNCH.
How big is that bag?
Tim Ferriss: This bag is — how many ounces
is this?
Let's see.
This is 10 ounces.
So we've got the CØCKPUNCH Miami Vice magenta
and teal type colors in the front.
We've got all the greater houses on the side.
We've got the eightfold arena icon on that
—
Kevin Rose: So cool.
Tim Ferriss: — opposite side, which is also
for the clerics' house, Mnemos.
And then we've got the description on the
back, QR code to the whole story.
And then we have the UPC, which means that
this is retail ready.
So I will have some announcements in the not-too-distant
future.
Kevin Rose: Oh, fuck.
I've got to buy some more of your NFTs.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
This coffee, holy shit.
I've never been a meth addict and I don't
want to trivialize it.
But when I was testing for this, I didn't
understand how real coffee masters and baristas
test coffee.
So I was doing multiple cups of coffee for
every variation that I tested, and I was drinking
12 cups of coffee a day.
I was so cracked out.
It was not ideal.
But I did test dozens and dozens of varieties,
and ultimately ended up on —
Kevin Rose: Ethiopian.
What mix is it?
Tim Ferriss: Oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah.
For sure.
This is Bombay Sidama Ethiopia.
This is Ethiopia Mother Station Washed.
Kevin Rose: Ethiopian coffees are just so
chill.
Nobody's offended.
Everyone just loves them.
They're just right down the fairway.
They're not too heavy, not too light.
They just give you a good flavor profile.
Nobody's pissed.
Tim Ferriss: Not too oily.
This is also medium blend.
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
Good solid medium roast.
Tim Ferriss: And I want to give credit where
credit is due.
This is roasted on a Bellwether.
So Bellwether is all electric.
The lowest carbon imprint coffee that you
can purchase.
It's all electric, which also makes it very
replicable, which is super interesting, right?
Because when you're using analog roasting
technology, there's a pretty high degree of
variance.
Whereas with Bellwether, and Bellwether is
B-E-L-L-W-E-T-H-E-R, it is all electric.
So you can dial in specs and really replicate
on demand, which is impressive to me.
I've been very impressed with their consistency.
Kevin Rose: So I've got to say, on the whole
conversation we had earlier about the CØCKPUNCH
name, if you go the route of stimulant drinks/male
—
Tim Ferriss: It's perfect.
It's perfect.
Kevin Rose: — enhancement, you're fucking
set, dude.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, yeah, it's right down the
fairway.
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
The CØCKPUNCH pills at the 7-Eleven behind
the counter that just get you going, you're
good.
Tim Ferriss: Right at the impulse purchase
row, right next to 5-Hour Energy.
Kevin Rose: Do you need a lift?
CØCKPUNCH.
Tim Ferriss: CØCKPUNCH.
Yeah.
And also all of my proceeds are going to the
Foundation, so they go directly to early stage
science and all that stuff.
Kevin Rose: Dude, that new jet that you guys
bought for your foundation, it's beautiful.
Tim Ferriss: You're such a prick.
Kevin Rose: Did you get a G6?
Tim Ferriss: I do not have a jet for the Foundation.
Kevin is punching me in the nuts, as per usual.
#CØCKPUNCH.
Kevin Rose: Okay.
Tim Ferriss: All right.
What else you got?
Kevin Rose: I've got two more things to say.
So one thing, and this one here, I'm about
three months into testing.
It's called OneSkin.
And I am not a person that goes out and buys
skin products.
But I have said, as I've gotten older, you
think about your crow's feet and all the other
shit you have going on, eyebrows and all this
stuff.
Eyebrows are fine, but I don't know why — right
here, this part right here.
Tim Ferriss: No wine involved in this podcast.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, exactly.
But what got me interested is they isolated
— this is a very science-driven team that
isolated a peptide that clears out senescent
cells.
And —
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
It basically euthanizes all the people in
the senior living home, basically?
Kevin Rose: Pretty much.
Tim Ferriss: From a cell perspective?
Kevin Rose: It makes all the bad cells die
and all the fresh ones live and lines go away.
I think this is all bullshit.
But here's the thing.
Rhonda Patrick was the first one to talk about
it because she was convinced by the science.
And then David Sinclair also tweeted about
it because he was really convinced by the
science.
And I'm like, "Listen, these are two people
that are way above my pay grade that on the
science side, I respect.
And if they're talking about this peptide
and they're liking the peer reviewed articles
that are coming out about it, or the science
is coming out about it, I'm going to pay attention."
There's one other person that tweeted about
it too.
But anyway, I picked some up and I'm three
months in and I'm starting to notice little
tiny changes just in skin quality and less
bumpiness that I would have and more just
supple — I've also had a lot of pizza lately,
so I probably have fatter cheeks —
Tim Ferriss: You look very supple.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, pleasantly plump.
But I would say that in general, I'm pretty
impressed.
So I just want to throw that out there.
I'm not the scientist, but a couple amazing
scientists have already recommended this.
It's called OneSkin.
Tim Ferriss: What's the name of this thing?
Kevin Rose: OneSkin.
Tim Ferriss: OneSkin.
Kevin Rose: O-N-E?
Tim Ferriss: I'm not an investor.
Kevin Rose: OneSkin?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, just O-N-E, skin.
And they don't have this extensive product
line of all these things.
There's three things you can buy, a cleanser,
an eye cream, and a lotion.
Kevin Rose: I like that.
I like that.
It's not a thousand things.
Tim Ferriss: More and more, I like a few SKUs.
If you have a thousand things, I'm like, "All
right, you're lining your pipeline with all
this shit to feed me as a customer."
But if you have one, two, three things, all
right, you're really focused on refining that
product.
Kevin Rose: I have a buddy that had lost a
bunch of weight lately and had a bunch of
lines in his neck and so he started applying
a bunch of this stuff to his neck and he's
like, "I'm noticing some results."
And I was like, "This is interesting."
It's worth letting other people try and see
what they think.
Tim Ferriss: My crow's feet are like fucking
brontosaurus feet at this point.
They're so fucking — they're out of control.
Kevin Rose: Dude, you should try it on one
eye for three months.
That'd be fucking cool, right?
Let's see what happens.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, that's a good idea.
That's a great idea.
Try it on one eye.
Kevin Rose: On your dates, you're like — you're
all fucked up.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
End up the crow's feet pirate.
That'd be great.
Kevin Rose: Just one eye.
Your date's like, "Oh, something's going on."
All right.
Tim Ferriss: What was it called?
No, no, no.
OneSkin.
Kevin Rose: OneSkin.
Yeah.
Anyway.
Lastly, this is a Peter Attia recommendation.
I wanted a really clean, clean, clean, clean
protein for when I make shakes and work out.
You probably know about ProMix, right?
Tim Ferriss: No, I don't know anything about
them.
Kevin Rose: Oh.
So this is Attia's favorite protein, or at
least it was as of a couple months ago.
Tim Ferriss: Is he an investor in ProMix?
Kevin Rose: I don't think so.
No.
It's called ProMix.
The founders, I was reading up on who's behind
it and it's just insanely, insanely clean.
Grass fed, hormone-free cows, minimally processed.
There's a lot of them that are out there like
this.
But I know Attia has a whole SWAT team of
people that do all the due diligence for him
when he's considering anything new.
And if he's going to say something's interesting,
I pay attention.
And they actually make these little tiny bars
that are whey protein little rice crispy treats,
kind of thing.
But they don't spike your glucose, because
I wear my continuous glucose monitor.
And it puts on — I think they're either
15 or 20 grams of protein.
And so I just have those as snacks that I
travel with as well.
So ProMix is his favorite protein, as of the
last time I chatted with him.
Tim Ferriss: So, ProMix.
And then do you want to mention this rice
cooker?
Kevin Rose: Oh, yeah.
Tim Ferriss: I think that might be interesting.
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
So I found a rice cooker.
I don't have a link to it in front of me.
But there was a rice cooker that I stumbled
upon.
So I love rice.
But for me, as someone that's —
Tim Ferriss: Me too.
Rice is fucking delicious.
It's so good.
Kevin Rose: It's so good.
And Tim, back in the day, and you'll remember
this quite well, but when you were into continuous
glucose monitors and then you got me into
them shortly after, you used to have to manually
inject yourself with that big ass syringe.
Do you remember, to put those in?
Tim Ferriss: Oh, so bad.
It was so bad.
Kevin Rose: Do you remember how bad —
Tim Ferriss: It was like a barbecue fork tong
that you had to stick in your abdomen.
It was really bad.
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
And you would watch the needle go in.
There was no quick action.
You had to push it in, then push it out.
Tim Ferriss: Terrible.
Kevin Rose: And then you would get this continuous
glucose monitor, and this was whatever, 10
years ago.
And you started doing it and I thought you
were crazy.
And then I copied you two months later and
started doing it.
Three months later, started doing it.
And one of the things I noticed, and I've
noticed since my entire time doing CGMs, is
that rice is my biggest offender.
If I eat a cup of rice, my shit is through
the roof on the glucose side.
And everybody's different.
Everybody has different microbiome.
There's a whole slew of factors on what happens
here.
But here's the interesting thing.
Toshiba, who is a trusted brand, came out
with a "low-carb rice cooker."
And I was like, "What the fuck is this?
Low-carb.
That's bullshit.
Right?
We all know rice is high carb.
What are they talking about?
Brown rice?"
All this shit, right?
Even brown rice spikes me, by the way.
So I did the research and what they've done
is they created this clever little basket.
They figured out that a typical rice cooker,
99.9 percent of rice cookers, you pour the
water in, cook the rice, it stews in its own
water, and your rice is done.
You scoop it in your bowl.
A bunch of the starch, call it 70 or so percent
of it, is released in that water during the
process of actually making and cooking the
rice.
So Toshiba invented a new rice cooker, they
call it their fuzzy logic technology rice
cooker that has a basket that lets all of
the starchy water drain to the bottom, and
you end up with a much lower glycemic load.
It cuts the carbs by 34 percent.
Sorry, 37 percent reduction in carbohydrate.
And dude, I ate a cup of rice, and I'm telling
you, I can see it on my CGM.
It does not spike me nearly as much as the
full rice, which I thought was pretty awesome.
I wouldn't have believed this in anyone else,
but Toshiba came out with it, and I was like,
okay, "If Toshiba's going to put their name
behind it, they must've done the research."
It's 179 bucks.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, they're a big dog.
Kevin Rose: It's $179.
If you want to just cut a little bit of carbs
out of you or if rice is a big offender for
you.
It works with oatmeal, it works with the whole
slew.
Brown rice, white rice and quinoa, the whole
range of things.
But anyway, I just thought it was really cool.
It's got 1,852 ratings with four and a half
out of five stars.
4.6 stars out of five.
So people love it.
300 plus have bought it in the last month.
Tim Ferriss: Let me ask you this.
Taste wise, is it as good?
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
I couldn't tell the difference.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
Kevin Rose: A little bit on the texture.
Little tiny bit on the texture.
But I'd say, call it a maybe five to seven
percent delta from what you're normally experiencing
on rice.
So you're not pissed.
It's fine.
Nobody's complaining.
Tim Ferriss: That's a big deal.
That's a big deal.
I fucking love rice.
There are so many carbs that I can —
Kevin Rose: Rice is the best.
Tim Ferriss: — I'm like, "Whatever.
I can do without it."
I love rice.
Oh, my god, do I love rice.
Kevin Rose: When you go hog, full hog on something,
cheat, cheat night, what do you do?
I'll tell you what I did two nights ago.
I went with Darya and we had a couple martinis.
Tim Ferriss: All right, you go.
You go first.
Kevin Rose: And I pulled out out of the fridge
— I had this mixed berry — it was a berry
cookie ice cream or some shit.
Do you feel like hell when you crush an entire
pint of ice cream?
I feel like I've just sinned beyond belief.
It’s the worst.
Tim Ferriss: It's been a while since I've
crushed a whole pint of ice cream.
My weaknesses are super clear.
My weaknesses are cheesecake.
So my question for any wait staff is from
one to 10, no seven allowed, how good is your
cheesecake?
And if they give me an eight, nine, or a 10,
I'll do the cheesecake.
There's cheesecake, and then there's carrot
cake.
Kevin Rose: Carrot cake.
Tim Ferriss: So those are like two — oh,
my God.
But it has to be super moist, and the icing
has to be really, really, really good.
Kevin Rose: I also can't have big chunks of
carrot in it.
If it has big chunks of carrot, I'm just eating
carrots.
Tim Ferriss: No, I don't want — carrot cake
is a joke.
It's fucking cake, right?
Kevin Rose: Right.
Tim Ferriss: I mean, no, if it's got huge
chunks of carrot, I'm not Bugs Bunny.
I don't need that.
Kevin Rose: Exactly.
Tim Ferriss: I don't have a carrot deficiency.
Kevin Rose: Some people do that though.
I've had some fucking carrots in there and
I'm just like, "Why are there chunks of carrot?"
Tim Ferriss: I'm not into it.
No.
So those two, I will always go for.
Pint of ice cream, and look, if it's in front
of me, I'm sure I'll eat it.
If I've had especially two drinks, two glasses
or more of any drink —
Kevin Rose: Like tonight?
Tim Ferriss: Like tonight.
So martinis, you mentioned martinis.
Kevin Rose: I love a good martini.
Tim Ferriss: Is it an old fucker thing that
they end up turning to martinis?
Because I have become more and more interested
in martinis.
Kevin Rose: Oh, my god, dude.
So here's the deal, dude.
Martinis, the thing that is so beautiful about
them is that if you order it correctly, it
is spirit clean.
So it's not a heavy — there's no sugar.
So here's what I do.
I say, "Give me a gin martini."
I typically go with — I like the less botanical
gins.
So I'll do a Boodles —
Tim Ferriss: Me too.
Kevin Rose: — or something that's just less
botanical.
And then I'll add in two olives, and I'll
say, "Extra dry, extra cold."
And then you're good to go.
And just a tiny bit of vermouth.
So on the dry side, rinse the glass with vermouth.
And then so it's mainly gin and you've got
those couple olives in there and you're good
to go.
Tim Ferriss: What is your opinion on espresso
in martinis?
Kevin Rose: I mean, I only do those at my
friend's bachelor parties or whatever, when
you're like, "I'm going to be out till 2:00
a.m." because otherwise caffeine fucks me
late at night.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Manhattan speedball.
Yep.
I love espresso martinis.
I've got to be honest.
Kevin Rose: Dude, they're really good.
If you're on a date, go to town, son.
That's a great way to go out and have fun.
Tim Ferriss: I'm back on the field.
I'm not the young man I once was.
My qi has been diminished.
I need to compensate with caffeine.
Kevin Rose: Tim, you've got to move out here,
dude.
This is fertile ground.
Tim Ferriss: I don't know if I can deal with
it.
I don't know if I can deal with it.
Honestly.
It's too intoxicating.
How much time do you want to spend falling
down the rabbit hole with Alice in Wonderland?
It's intoxicating.
Kevin Rose: Do you think they're all kind
of — can we bleep something out if I say
it?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, of course.
Kevin Rose: Do you think they're all [--] out
here, or do you think it's like — let's
bleep that part out.
Are they all that type of person, or do you
think it's like, because I think there’s
good people out here.
Tim Ferriss: No, no, no.
Kevin Rose: Not that she's a bad person.
Tim Ferriss: This edit’s going to be amazing.
So I think there are amazing people.
It's just you have to really wade through
and sort through a lot in L.A. to get to the
signal.
It's very hard.
Kevin Rose: What are you looking for in a
relationship long term?
What are your top go-tos, what do you want?
Tim Ferriss: What do I want?
I want someone with —
Kevin Rose: Don't say physical —
Tim Ferriss: I mean the physical matters.
Let's not lie about it.
Kevin Rose: No doubt.
Don't get me wrong.
I know what you want on the physicals.
Tim Ferriss: I'll give Darya a compliment.
Darya takes very good care of herself.
Kevin Rose: Oh, dude, she works out two hours
a day.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I know.
That's not trivial, right?
And it's for her as much as it is for you.
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
It's not for me.
Tim Ferriss: It is a significant thing.
Right?
The physical practice is a significant thing.
So there's that.
I mean, I like strong, physically attuned
women.
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Now, strong doesn't mean big.
I'm not looking for a CrossFit games winner
necessarily.
But someone who is very physically attuned
is important to me.
That's important to me personally and is important
in a partner.
Outside of that, I mean, I think that I'm
looking for someone who has a clear sense
of identity and direction because that direction
may change, but if someone doesn't have a
clear, demonstrated ability to focus for at
least a few years, I find that the relationship
becomes this nitpicky project.
Kevin Rose: Well, you don't want them also
just hanging on, right?
They've got to be their own show too, right?
Not show, but you know what I mean.
They've got to have their own shit going on.
Tim Ferriss: They have to have their own shit
going on.
Kevin Rose: How should we wrap things up?
I've got way more things to talk about, but
I know we've been going for a while.
Tim Ferriss: I mean, I'll add one.
All right, so let's take a departure speech.
Kevin Rose: One more.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, sure.
So I'll give one.
So mine is an app.
You can find it on browser, on laptop as well,
called Airalo, A-I-R-A-L-O, which is for cellular
data overseas.
And it is the easiest, most reliable approach
that I've found to cellular data overseas.
So if you're going to any country, you can
buy a cellular data plan.
Even if, for instance, in my case, Verizon
may not support —
Kevin Rose: Oh, I can help you here.
I've got a better solution than this, but
go ahead.
Tim Ferriss: All right, well I can't wait
to hear.
In case of Verizon, yeah, they want to "upgrade"
you, in quotation marks, all the time to an
unlimited data plan.
But the cost question is open for me.
So I've used Airalo, which I have been very
happy with up to this point in time.
So what's your better alternative?
Kevin Rose: So here's something that most
people don't know is that iPhones in particular,
and I believe Android phones as well, they
can support multiple SIMs.
And at this point in time they're called eSIMs
because you don't actually need a SIM card.
Tim Ferriss: So Airalo is an eSIM.
Yeah.
Kevin Rose: Okay.
So Google Fi is just insane because internationally
they give you coverage in just so many countries.
I don't have the exact number, but I put on
a secondary plan.
So there's two things that this helps you
with.
My main plan is Verizon and I use that for
data because they have good 5G, I use it for
my main phone number.
No, sorry, I don't use my phone number.
I use it for data.
I use my phone number at Google Fi because
it's protected by two-factor authentication,
and all crazy security of Google Fi.
So SIM swaps are very, they just can't happen
because there's not a person to call, there's
a trick into doing a SIM swap.
You have to actually log in with your Google
account.
So use that Google Fi as your main number,
change the data to go to Verizon, so you get
the good data package, because you can do
this in the iPhone.
Tim Ferriss: So walk me through this just
to back up.
So I have a Verizon account.
What do I do?
Kevin Rose: Okay, so you want to transfer
your number to Google Fi.
Tim Ferriss: How do you do that?
Kevin Rose: Google Fi on the website will
walk you through it.
Now, Google Fi is not going to give you the
best data.
So what you then do is you say, "Okay, Verizon,
I love you, but you're going to be my data-only
plan."
And they charge $20 a month or something for
it.
It's data only.
Okay.
So that's your eSIM that is data only.
And then in the settings [they] say, "Hey,
where do you want to get your data from?"
And you say, "I want to get it from Verizon."
And then you've got the 5G network and you're
in the United States, you're good to go.
And then your security of your main phone
number is locked down by Google Fi.
So that's the most secure place that you can
have it.
Then, when you go abroad, because Google Fi
has all of these international connections,
it's like over 200 destinations they say,
they have coverage on, it's insanely cheap.
Their data plans are the cheapest that are
out there.
Then you go into your phone settings and say,
"Switch my data from Verizon to Google Fi."
So now you're Google Fi all the time when
you're international and one phone, you don't
have to switch phones or anything.
And so I have this little two-bar thing that
goes on.
They show you two bars on your phone when
you do both of the plans.
So it's great.
Tim Ferriss: I love it.
Boom.
So what is the infrastructure of Google Fi?
How are they providing that data?
Kevin Rose: They use multiple providers, but
it's mainly T-Mobile in the United States.
But it says that all plans include US, Canada,
and Mexico.
Unlimited plans and flexible plans data in
200-plus international destinations plus 5G
in select countries.
And their 5G country list just keeps growing
and growing.
It's great, man.
Every time I ever fly anywhere international,
I just turn on Google Fi and I get the highest
speed.
It's fantastic.
And it is so inexpensive.
Tim Ferriss: Amazing.
I'm on it.
All right, so I'm taking notes too folks.
All right, Kevin, you said you had one more.
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Do you have something else?
Kevin Rose: Last one.
I've got a bunch of investing-related stuff,
but you can get that on my podcast, kevinrose.com.
There'll be a link to the podcast at the top.
But I would say the last thing, which is the
absolute no-brainer right now: screw buying
individual bonds.
Rates are changing all the time.
Vanguard, and this is not investment advice,
this is just me saying what I do personally.
When I do my bonds, rather than do bond funds
or crazy medium-term or long-term bonds, we
don't want to screw that given where rates
are at.
VUSXX is the Vanguard fund that I use, and
I think it's a no-brainer in that it's a hundred
percent treasury-based.
So they buy US government treasuries.
So all these banks right now are being like,
"Hey, we'll give you four and a half percent.
We'll give you four percent."
Blah blah.
this fund.
Right now it's, and this obviously changes
day by day, non-investment advice again, right
now it's 5.32 percent compound yield on Vanguard
with the smallest management fee and they're
just buying US treasuries.
So that's what I'm doing on the bond side
right now.
Everything else, index invested, set it, forget
it, except for Nvidia.
I also think that there's some upside in AMD
potentially on the low end AI side.
Tim Ferriss: Wait, what?
Hold on.
Say that again.
Kevin Rose: Nvidia —
Tim Ferriss: You said Nvidia.
Kevin Rose: Nvidia, I think’s, going to
three trillion.
I think it's going to three trillion.
Tim Ferriss: The new plutonium.
It's like the new arms race.
Kevin Rose: AI is the shit.
It's not going away anytime soon.
It's not a fad.
This is not VR/AR bullshit.
This is really going to change the entire
world.
Nvidia is the dominant player in this space.
The stock, if you look at it, it's scary as
because the run up has just been the most
insane steep climb you've ever seen.
I think long-term it's going to be a $3 trillion
company.
It's close to two.
Hovering at two right now.
This is a growth play.
This is not an angel investment.
I hold some just because I like to hold a
few individual stocks.
I think AMD is a good cheap play for this.
They still have a pretty high price to earnings
ratio.
And also I met with a good friend of mine
that's an insanely smart PhD from MIT, that
is one of the earliest inventors of a bunch
of AI.
Sold his company to Apple.
I won't name him, but he told me that the
problem with AMD is they have an underdeveloped
software stack for AI, but they're rapidly
trying to fix that because that's the biggest
issue that AMD has right now.
AMD is way cheaper than Nvidia right now.
So if I was going to say, okay, I've got X
number of dollars for an AI play, two things,
dollar cost average your way in.
So you're not buying the high and not buying
the low, you're just spending a fixed amount
of money over six months or so to slowly work
your way into the market.
If you don't don't know what dollar cost averaging
is, Google search it.
And then AMD would be like, if I put 75 percent
in Nvidia, I put 25 percent in AMD — non-investment
advice — TSMC is the manufacturer of all
the chips.
TSMC makes Nvidia chips, AMD chips.
They are the backbone of this entire world
when it comes to manufacturing CPUs, GPUs.
The biggest concern there is they're in Taiwan.
Hotly contested China issues.
I don't touch it because I worry about China.
I talked to my buddy, again, my buddy that's
really, really deep on the AI side, one of
my most trusted advisors on the AI side.
He said that, and this was a big shocker to
me, he told me that Facebook invested in AI
a few years ago and bought up some of the
best engineers in AI.
So he would not be surprised if Facebook unveils
some crazy shocking, amazing AI tech in the
next six months to a year.
And so I trust him.
I'm not buying Facebook stock.
I think they're fucked up for a whole bunch
of other reasons.
They're spending way too much on VR and AR,
but that was eyeopening to me.
The other two big players is Google and Amazon.
Google's only showing a little bit of their
cards right now, not revealing the whole thing.
Bard, their AI is insanely, insanely locked
down.
The real Bard behind the scenes, if you're
at Google, it's 10x improvement over what
they have publicly available.
Tim Ferriss: It's a lot better.
I'll give a wink.
It's a lot better.
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
Last thing, NTDOY, Nintendo, Super Mario Bros.
Second highest, what is it when they have
the sales, box office sales and of all animated
films.
The Super Mario Bros. Amazing movie.
They're sitting on a fuck ton of IP.
So a nibble for me is Nintendo.
I nibble because I see them playing with Universal
Studios.
Could they be the next Disney?
I don't know, man.
Zelda could be the next Lord of the Rings.
There's a lot of IP locked up there in Nintendo.
I think that that could be interesting.
Tim Ferriss: That's interesting.
That's fun.
Yeah.
Whoever are wondering also, Nintendo, way
back in the day, Nintendo.
Kevin Rose: Nintendo, I knew you were going
to do that.
You always do that do that shit.
Tim Ferriss: Initially they made trading cards,
Hanafuda trading cards in Japan, and they
still make them.
Kevin Rose: They were so oishī.
They're just beautiful and delicious.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, delicious.
Yeah.
Utsukushī.
Very beautiful.
All right, man.
Well fucking a, we've covered a lot.
That was great.
So nice to see you, buddy.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, good to see you, brother.
This was fun.
Tim Ferriss: And anything else you'd like
to say?
Kevin, you're going to point people to the
new podcast, the resurrected podcast.
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
If you head to kevinrose.com, it'll be at
the header there.
I'll make sure it's up.
And I appreciate you all for listening.
I promise some wild crazy moments and some
fun stuff.
So thank you for tuning in.
Tim Ferriss: Kevin is very, very, very, very
good at his format, so check it out and for
the show notes from this, God knows what kind
of mess my team will have to untangle.
Tim.blog/podcast.
You'll find links to all sorts of shit.
And —
Kevin Rose: Aesop hand sanitizer for when
you shit yourself.
Tim Ferriss: Exactly.
Hashtag Aesop disaster pants, sponsorship
incoming.
All right guys, thanks for tuning in.
Talk to you soon.
Bye.
Kevin Rose: See you soon.